Hallo Stefan.
Sag mal, jetzt wo Weihnachten rum ist, wie war's denn?
Ach, es ging so. Ich wollte hier eigentlich das Traumschiff gucken, aber das geht ja nicht mehr.
So, nun klappt es für alle, die live dabei sind. Es gab ja eben schon einen Versuch von Wolfgang, mir zu erklären, was es mit diesem Traumschiff oder wie auch immer auf sich hat. Wir haben schon geklärt, er hat es nicht geguckt, weil ihm Schauspieler fehlen. Den ersten, den er nannte, konnte ich noch live googeln. Danach Siegfried Rauch. Das war der Captain.
Genau und vor allem gilt das Argument grundsätzlich nicht, denn wir können ja den Pfad der Wissenschaft folgen. Wir haben sowohl für, also es gibt eine Zufriedenheitsforschung. Die Deutsche Post macht immer so eine Glücksstudie, die ist gar nicht so schlecht, aber es gibt grundsätzlich auch so eine Zufriedenheitsforschung, denn darum geht es ja am Ende. Man liegt auf dem Sterbebett und worauf blickt man zurück, was war einem wichtig und so weiter. Gerade jetzt wohl so viel gestorben worden in Deutschland. Und wir können mit ziemlicher Sicherheit sagen, dass es erstens an der sozialen Ungleichheit liegt, wo die Beträge anzusiedeln sind, ab denen man sich sicher und aufgehoben fühlt. Und man braucht in Amerika zum Beispiel sehr viel mehr Geld und mehr Einkommen, um sich sicher und aufgehoben zu fühlen. Denn man weiß, wenn mir das wegbricht, dann muss ich alles anders organisieren. Also dann fällt man nicht nur aus dem Beruf raus und irgendwie in den Sozialstaat hinein, sondern dann ist gleich alles futsch. Dann kriegt man kein Arbeitslosengeld, keine Krankenversicherung mehr und so. Dann ist alles hinüber. In Deutschland wissen wir, dass so ab 60.000 Euro persönlichem Einkommen pro Jahr im Grunde schon sehr schwer wird, den Menschen zufriedener zu machen. Wir haben diese Diskussion, da habe ich mal im Fernsehpodcast gespielt aus Amerika, wo ein Kommentator der New York Times am Tisch sitzt bei PBS und sagt, also Trump hat dem Volk eine Billion geschenkt und Biden kommt ins Amt und schenkt auch nochmal eine Billion und dann kommt gleich das nächste Gesetz mit zwei Billionen. Aber die Menschen hassen die Politik und die Politiker wissen langsam auch nicht mehr, was sollen sie tun. Jedes Jahr fünf Billionen ins Volk schenken. So ja, also selbst wenn man dann sagt, das ist ja nur Triggledown verteilt so bei Trump, aber es kam halt wirklich an. Also die Leute haben halt einfach einen höheren Gehaltscheck bekommen. War ja auch so angelegt. Und während Corona waren die Arbeitslosenhilfen so hoch, dass die Leute wirklich gesagt haben, warum soll ich eigentlich zurück in den Beruf gehen? Ich kriege ja jetzt gerade 1000 Dollar pro Monat einfach in meinem Briefkasten als Check, also Bargeld in Briefkasten. Und trotzdem sind die Leute unglaublich unzufrieden. Und so wie wir nach oben hin relativ zügig so eine Grenze haben, wo man so einem Banker wirklich also sehr viel mehr in mehrere Faktoren mehr als ein Kanzlergehalt zahlen muss, damit er dann in so einem spieltheoretischen, es ist aber mehr als mein Kollege oder darüber noch irgendwelche Zufriedenheitswerte rausangelt, gilt das nach unten auch. Also wir kennen die Gehaltsgrenzen nach unten, auf dem ein lebenswertes Leben nicht mehr möglich ist. Also wo man es einfach nur noch den ganzen Tag über Geld nachdenkt, keine langfristigen Pläne mehr macht, nur noch Angst davor hat, wieder Situationen. Das ist ein bisschen wie Analphabet sein, wo man quasi nur noch unter Vermeidung, hoffentlich muss ich nichts lesen, hoffentlich kriegt keiner raus, dass ich nicht lesen kann und so weiter, wo man nur noch vermeidet, dass die Kinder nicht zum Kindergeburtstag eingeladen werden, dass die Nachbarn eigentlich irgendwo hin einladen, dass man nicht irgendwo ein Gefälligkeitsgeschenk mitbringen muss und so weiter. Und das macht halt die Leute wirklich irre. In dem Maße ist es dann auch wirklich bestürzend. Der 41 Prozent der Alleinerziehenden sind arm. Was auch bedeutet in Deutschland, das ist ein ganz großes eminzipatorisches Argument, das ist einfach eine grundsätzlich große biografische Gefahr für alle Frauen. Sobald der Mann sie verlässt, sind sie mit den Kindern auf sich allein gestellt. Und dann ist egal, aus welcher Riege man herausfällt, also aus welcher Schicht, man kommt dann einfach in ein paar Jahren, wenn der Mann nichts dagegen tut und nicht Gnade zeigt oder so, kommt man als Frau da einfach mit Kindern an, unten in der Armut.
Wo ist denn eigentlich die Armut in Deutschland? Denn die ist ein bisschen ungleich verteilt, kann man sagen. Oder nicht ein Ruck, sondern ein Riss geht durch dieses Land.
Der Wohlstandsgraben zwischen dem Süden, also zwischen Bayern und Baden-Württemberg auf der einen Seite und dem Rest der Republik auf der anderen Seite hat sich verfestigt, wenn nicht sogar noch weiter vertieft. Der Abstand zwischen einzelnen Bundesländern hat ebenfalls extrem zugenommen. Wenn man sich das bestplatzierte Land anschaut, Bayern haben wir eine Quote von 11, 6 Prozent und beim schlecht platziertesten, dem Bundesland Bremen, sind es 28, 4 Prozent.
Ha, vergleich das mal mit der Impfquote. Ja, interessanterweise.
Ja, aber es ist erschreckend, diese Zahlen. Man denkt, wir sind ja ein Land, das jetzt auch nicht so unglaublich groß ist. Wir können jetzt nicht sagen, na ja, das ist ja auch ein halber Kontinent, sondern wir sind ein relativ kleines Land und dass wir trotzdem eine solche Diskrepanz zwischen den Bundesländern haben. Wir haben über die Schüler schon gesprochen. Wenn sie in der Schule sind, dann tragen sie nicht so sehr zum Pandemiegeschehen bei. Wenn sie nicht in der Schule sind, dann haben sie auch andere Probleme, vor allem die Schüler, die aus armen Familien stammen. Wir haben es geahnt, bekommen sie aber noch mal schwarz auf weiß.
Dass Kinder in beengten Wohnverhältnissen ohne vernünftige Digitalausstattung im Homeschooling so gut wie ohne Chancen sind. Und das hat Armut in 2020 gerade bei den Kindern geprägt. Wir haben in der Regel in den letzten Jahren immer 50.000 Schulabbrecher gehabt. Also junge Menschen, die ohne Abschluss vor den Schulen gingen. Experten rechnen jetzt mittlerweile mit einer 6-stelligen Zahl, weil im Homeschooling viele nicht mithalten konnten.
Also mehr als verdoppeln wird sich die Zahl der Schulabbrecher. Und das sind in der Regel Schüler aus armen Familien. Und wenn man sich diese Zahl noch mal vergegenwärtigt, dann muss man auch wirklich fragen, wie es sein kann, dass man so wenig darüber gesprochen hat. Also über das Leid, was dadurch auch produziert wurde bei den Schülern und was ja auch dann einfach den Weg in die Zukunft extrem beschwert. Klar, kann man auch die Schule abbrechen und später noch mal auf einem anderen Weg wieder zur Schule zurückführen. Aber wie vielen gelingt das? Wie vielen gelingt das nicht? Oder wer bekommt auch mit dieser Frustration, die er erlebt hat mit diesem Unterricht vor der Webcam in beengten Verhältnissen, dann von Anfang an den Eindruck, diese Stadt interessiert sich überhaupt nicht für mich. Warum sollte ich mich dafür interessieren?
Und dabei kommen die Schüler noch gut weg im Vergleich zu den Studenten. Das sind ja unglaubliche Zustände, dass selbst die Uni-Bibliotheken alle noch geschlossen haben. Und Bücher, die dann über, es ist quasi nur noch überall Fernuni und Fernleihe zurückgegeben werden, kommen erst mal drei Wochen in Quarantäne, weil das Uni-Bibliothek Kars Mitarbeiter, die wollen einfach nichts damit zu tun haben. Und die freuen sich auch sehr, dass sie Bibliothek für sich haben, wo sie nicht abends immer die Stellrevision machen müssen, um zu gucken, ob alle Bücher ordentlich im Regal stehen. Bei den Unis ist mittlerweile wirklich das Problem, dass sich diejenigen, die die Uni organisieren und vor allem die, wie ich kürzlich gelernt habe, Dimi-Do-Professoren, die jetzt nur noch Do-Professoren sind, also Dienstag, Mittwoch, Donnerstag, es ist nur noch Donnerstag, dass die sich sehr eingerichtet haben, nicht von Studenten belastet und belästigt zu werden. Also bei Schulen haben wir jetzt ein Grundrecht durchs Bundesverfassungsgericht, da ist gesagt, es gibt ein Recht auf Schule. Für Studenten ist richtig Land unter gerade.
Ja, ich habe eine E-Mail bekommen von einem Studenten, der hatte diese Podiumsdiskussionen gesehen, als ich dann Lübeck war und über die Jugend und Corona sprach. Und der hat das einfach mal geschildert. Der hat gesagt, ich habe angefangen zu studieren mit Corona. Ich war bislang nur ein paar Mal, glaube ich, an der Uni, sonst überhaupt nicht in einer fremden Stadt. Glücklicherweise dann noch WG-Mitbewohner. Sonst hätte man überhaupt keine sozialen Kontakte. Es sei ein unglaublich trauriges Dasein. Ich war froh, dass ich das mal angesprochen habe. Und dann bekommst du halt eine lange E-Mail, wo das so ausgebreitet wird. Und das ist ganz erschütternd zu lesen. Und das findet in der gesellschaftlichen Debatte nicht statt. Die sitzen alle nicht in den Talkshows. Und es ist eigentlich so, wir kommen ja noch auf Chile zu sprechen, dass wir dringend Studentenproteste eigentlich bräuchten.
Absolut. Da bin ich zur Urteil-Defuhr.
Dringend. Ja, Arme wurden noch mehr belastet durch die Pandemie. Hier nochmal Uri Schneider.
Das heißt, die Menschen, die ohnehin in Alltagsgrundsicherung oder Hartz IV leben, hatten noch mal mit enormen finanziellen Belastungen zu tun in dieser Pandemie. Und deswegen hatten wir uns so weniger Verständnis, dass im ganzen Jahr 2020 die Bundesregierung nichts übrig hatte für diese armen Menschen. Wir haben milliardenschwere Schutzschirme aufgespannt, ein milliardenschweres Konjunkturprogramm aufgelegt. Doch es dauerte bis 2021, bevor endlich allen Menschen in Hartz IV und in der Altersgrundsicherung wenigstens einmalig 150 Euro zur Verfügung gestellt wurden. Und es dauerte bis 2021, man muss sich das vorstellen, bis die Bundesregierung sich durchregen konnte, Menschen in Hartz IV und in der Altersgrundsicherung wenigstens einmalig einen Gutschein für zehn Masken, für zehn FFP2-Masken zu überlassen.
Ja, man hat fast den Eindruck, Corona betrifft wirklich nur die Wirtschaft und nicht die Menschen.
Es ist grandalös, also 150 Euro, dann einmal ausgestattet, dann mal zehn FFP2-Masken. Jeder weiß doch, was es kostet, wenn man mal ein bisschen krank ist. So wie ich das jetzt auch hatte. Dann kauft man Nasenspreis, dann kauft man noch ein Seil bei, dann muss man noch fünf Euro Aufschlag für das verschriebene Medikament bezahlen. So und dann lässt man der Apotheke einfach mal 25 Euro. Das ist für Leute, die in Armut leben, eine Katastrophe, wenn die 25 Euro mal noch dazukommen. Und wenn man denkt, naja, jetzt werden sich die Kinder noch untereinander anstecken, dann gibt es nochmal 25, nochmal 25 Euro, dann ist das etwas, was einen verzweifeln lässt und den Monat plötzlich zu lang werden lässt, um überhaupt noch genügend Nahrung auch zu kaufen. Und dass es dann eine Diskussion darüber gibt, ja wie viele Masken stellen wir denen jetzt zur Verfügung? Dann gibt man denen einmal zehn FFP2-Masken. Wir wissen, wie lang man mit FFP2-Masken nur zehn Stück auskommt. Also es ist skandalös, das zu hören. Ulrich Schneider nimmt dann auch die neue Regierung ins Gebet. Denn das war jetzt auch einfach nochmal zu sagen, so das waren die Merkel-Jahre. Und ich glaube, wir sollten, wenn wir an Merkel erinnern, uns eigentlich immer nur diese BPK erst einmal zu Gemüte führen. Dann können wir mal über alles andere sprechen. Jetzt die neue Koalition. Ja, da sind Ansätze und so weiter. Aber er sagt hier ganz klar, wie hoch muss der Hartz-IV-Satz denn sein? Und er findet nichts dazu im Koalitionsvertrag. Ich habe mir dann die Debatte angesehen im Bundestag. Eine Stunde lang von der Linken ja anberaumt, müssen wir jetzt einen Inflationsangleich zahlen für Hartz-IV-Empfänger und so was, damit die über die Runden kommen. Jetzt wurde der Antrag abgelehnt. Man weiß, dass Oppositionsanträge abgelehnt werden. Das ist so ein parlamentarisches Spiel. Aber ich habe die Debatte ja nur verfolgen wollen, weil ich dachte, hören wir mal was zum Satz. Wie wird er dann jetzt sein, diese Grundsicherung? Kein Wort dazu.
Dass in diesem Koalitionsvertrag kein Wort verloren wird über die Hartz-IV-Regelsätze. Die Hartz-IV-Regelsätze sind die ganz zentrale Stellschraube, wenn es darum geht, was ist das Existenzminimum? Was muss der Staat tatsächlich schützen? Was muss er Menschen mindestens zur Verfügung stellen? Wir haben jahrelange Diskussionen darum. Alle Praktiker wissen, mit dem, was jetzt gezahlt wird, demnächst 449 Euro, kommt man nicht über den Monat oder mit nicht mal 400 Euro oder nicht mal 300 Euro für ein Kind, da muss eine Erhöhung her. Wir wissen, der Regelsatz ist trickreich kleingerechnet, aber er wird im gesamten Qualitionsvertrag ausgesperrt. Wir sind der Auffassung, wer so viel über Würde, über Teilhabe und Respekt von Menschen spricht, der soll erst mal dafür sorgen, und das ist eine Frage des Respekts, dass alle Menschen in Deutschland überhaupt eine Chance haben, aus der Armut herauszukommen und über den Monat zu kommen.
Ja, Olaf Scholz beim Respekt zu packen ist gut, denn das ist Olaf Scholz sehr wichtig. Es gibt allerdings noch von ihm einen Ausschnitt, wie er sich sehr euphorisch über die Kindergrundsicherung äußert. Da ist er sehr gespannt. Mal gucken. Also, Sie haben ja jetzt begonnen. Klar, dieser Hartz-Vier-Regelsatz, da sind ja vor allem, also er hat es an die SPD hier adressiert, aber die grüne Jugend ist ja da sehr hinterher, dass es da zur Bewegung kommt. Mal schauen, würde ich sagen. Aber ansonsten eine sehr traurige Veranstaltung, die nach 23 Minuten oder so vorbei war. Es ist wie es ist. Mangelt es eigentlich an Geld? Ne, es mangelt nicht an Geld. Wir können ja mal kurz fatzenet lesen. Der Bund hat in diesem Jahr dank Negativzensen erneut Milliarden beim Schuldenmachen eingenommen. Bei der Emission von Bundeswertpapieren zur Finanzierung des Haushalts einschließlich Sondervermögen wurden, Zitat, Zahlung in Höhe von rund 5,855 Milliarden Euro vereinnahmt. Das geht aus einem der Nachrichtenagentur Reuters am Mittwoch vorliegenden Antwortschreiben von Finanzstaatssekretär Florian Toncar auf eine Anfrage des Bundestagsabgeordneten Christian Görker von der Linkspartei hervor. Ich bin darauf gestoßen, weil Görker seine Anfrage auf Twitter geteilt hat. Das Bundesfinanzministerium gibt nun an, dass die Durchschnittsrendite der emittierten Bundeswertpapiere bei minus 0, 56 Prozent liegt. Was bedeutet, umso mehr Schulden wir machen, umso mehr verdienen wir auch. Und wir haben jetzt Schulden gemacht und entsprechend 5,855 Milliarden Euro gewonnen. Trotz dieser Sachlage ist die Bundesregierung, natürlich vor allem durch FDP-Beteiligung, immer noch nicht davon überzeugt, dass es jetzt einfach mal Sinn macht, Schulden zu machen. Wir haben ja hier ausführlich mit Südekums Vorschlag uns schon befasst. Investitionsinstitutionen, sagen wir mal so, zu schaffen, die sich verschulden können, was aber nicht auf die Schuldenbremse angerechnet wird, weil durch die Verschuldung mit gezielter Investition einhergehend der Eigentumsgewinne, die auch Buchwert haben und so weiter, einhergehen. Also wenn Deutschland an, was weiß ich, Energieparks und so weiter beteiligt ist, die man finanziert, dann schafft man ja Vermögen. Das ist ja kein Konsum, sondern das ist ja klassischer Fall Investition. Die FDP hat sich ja bisher gesperrt. Jetzt musste allerdings Christian Lindner ja doch in den sauren Apfel beißen und die 60 Milliarden aus dem Corona-Schuldentopf mitschleppen in den neuen Haushalt und dort auch in der Sache umwidmen. Ja, er hat das sehr schön gemacht.
Und jetzt hat die CDU schon gesagt, CDU ist ganz entsetzt, wiederholt laufend, 60 Milliarden und suggeriert, lieber Rentner, die werden dir gerade weggenommen. Nein, überhaupt nicht. Also die würden die jetzt einfach gerne wieder in den, also das würden sie natürlich auch dann nicht machen. Sie würden das ja auch dann nutzen, nur wahrscheinlich für irgendeinen Unsinn. Dann würde Peter Altmaier nochmal alte Seilschaften aktivieren. Wer kann noch ein paar Milliarden brauchen? Aber grundsätzlich würden die es auch nicht zurückgeben. Aber die Idee, so wie die CDU das jetzt vorstellt, wäre, man sagt, die 60 Milliarden haben wir nicht gebraucht, die werfen wir wieder zurück und haben dadurch nicht ganz so hohe Schulden.
Ja, und man muss sich halt wirklich fragen, bei einer Bundesanleihe, die denjenigen, der sie kauft, Geld kostet, nämlich 0, 5 Prozent, die als Rendite beim Staat ankommt, wenn man jetzt zu denjenigen hingeht und sagt, hier hast du dein Geld wieder, gib uns mal die Staatsanleihe zurück, will der die überhaupt zurück? Und die Antwort ist ja nein, will die ja gar nicht zurück. Und das ist wirklich Wahnsinn, denn diese Bundesanleihen, die Geldkosten, sind zu 1, 7 Fach überzeichnet. Also man könnte sogar noch mal zwei, drei Milliarden mehr auftreiben und sowieso im laufenden Betrieb, sondern das war ja nur ein tagesaktuelles hineinstechen, hier zack, das ist das Angebot und dann kann man es nicht mal komplett bedienen, weil es noch mehr Leute gibt, die gerne Geld dafür bezahlen, Staatsanleihen zu haben. Also wir haben wieder den verrückten Modus, wie schon im Mai 2020, als wir hier schon darüber sprachen, damals hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt, die Schulden, die die Europäische Zentralbank macht, indem sie Staatsanleihen aufkauft und bisher ist ja europaweit 30 Prozent aller Staatsanleihen sind jetzt mittlerweile angekommen, einmal durch den Finanzmarkt getrieben und dann kam jetzt Bundesverfassungsgerichtstag, das muss zurückgezahlt werden, außer der Bundestag nickt das nochmal ab, haben sie dann ganz eilig gemacht und da haben wir uns auch schon gefragt, will die jemand zurück haben? Wo käme das Geld her? Also Gauweiler, der damals klagte, hat ja wirklich Angst, dass demnächst eine Steuererhöhung kommt, die ihn um 5 Billionen belastet, damit das bezahlt werden kann. Also völlig banal.
Ich habe ja Videos bei YouTube, wo Leute sagen, jetzt muss man sehen, dass man sein Geld versteckt im Garten.
Genau, Ausweichbewegungen zu Bitcoin, weil da ist man safe, wenn der Komet dann angeschlagen ist. Mit Bitcoin kann man noch bezahlen, wenn die Energie ausgefallen ist. Also wir haben wieder eine Wahnsinnskonstellation, in der das Bundesverfassungsgericht demnächst wieder darüber entscheiden muss, weil die CDU das will, wie man mit diesem Geld, das niemand will, weil man will lieber, wie Stephanie Kelten sagt, das grüne, nicht das gelbe Geld, nicht das grüne Geld, das ist das bargeld, das gelbe Geld sind die Staatsschulden. Man will lieber im sicheren Hafen bleiben. Man will nicht vertrieben werden aus dem Staatsschuldenhafen.
Das ist ja auch wieder jetzt etwas diskursiv interessantes oder auch medienpolitisch interessantes. Durch diese Klagen, die da stattfinden, die natürlich am Ende abgewiesen werden, es wird nicht am Ende so sein, dass die Ampel sagt, ach so, dann dürfen wir die nicht ausgeben, versucht man ja einfach, eine Öffentlichkeit zu schaffen für die Opposition. Also die Opposition schafft sich selbst eine Öffentlichkeit. Die Medien reagieren entsprechend darauf. Ist ja auch toll, wir waren wieder in Karlsruhe und und und, da wurde wieder gepoltert. Ja, das ist aber etwas, was immer Aufmerksamkeitsspanne wegnimmt oder Zeit wegnimmt, um über interessante Fragen zu sprechen. Nämlich, wie könnte man jetzt am sinnvollsten die 60 Milliarden investieren? Das wird am Ende gar nicht dann stattfinden. Dafür interessiert sich dann wieder kaum einer in der Öffentlichkeit, sondern man sieht hier wieder nur dieses Spiel zwischen verschiedenen Politikern, Kandidaten und und und. Und wir können jetzt schon mal auf die nächste Bundestagswahl blicken. Wird dann März, wenn er so gut vorgelegt hat, in Karlsruhe durchmarschieren? Also man kann sich ja diese ganzen Kommentare schon ausmalen.
Genau, und wir schauen mal kurz in einen dieser Diskurse. Denn wir kennen die Protagonisten, zum Beispiel Michael Hüther, der Chef des Instituts der deutschen Wirtschaft. Bisher eigentlich immer so als Lobbyarm der CDU erkannt, bis es zu diesem Moment kam als Hüther in einem Einspiel-Fählchen. Bei Anne Will sagte, Schuldenbremse und kluge Politik ist die Quadratur des Kreises. Und dann Ralf Brinkhaus als CDU-Fraktionschef sich da rechtfertigen müsste, wie das denn sein kann, dass nicht mal mehr Michael Hüther nach der CDU-Linie folgt. Also ich kenne Michael Hüther gut, das ist ein Freund von mir, aber hier folge ich ihm mal nicht. Und darauf hat man es dann bewenden lassen. Und dankenswerterweise hat Michael Hüther, so wie alle, heute auch einen Podcast, zusammen mit Bert Rürup, den wir auch noch kennen aus dieser neoliberalen Hyperbubble. Und die beiden reden jetzt im Handelsblatt über das Geld, über Haushalte. Und ich habe gedacht, wir fallen gleich die Ohren ab. Das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein, dass wir hier selbst Michael Hüther plötzlich sehen, wie er so Südekommen liest und dann feststellt, der Südekommen hat sich das nicht nur ausgedacht, sondern der übersetzt im Grunde so eine internationale Debatte mal ins Deutsche. Wow, sind da aber viele einer Meinung, das ist ja gar nicht meine Meinung, was mache ich denn jetzt? Und einfach mal umschwenkt. Und das ist einfach grandios zu hören. Wir machen das hier in vier Clips. Zum einen steigt Hüther ja ein Klima- und Digitalisierung als Schattenhaushalt. Also diese 60 Milliarden, die jetzt aus Corona übergenommen werden, um dann zum Klima- und Digitalisierung zur Verfügung zu stehen.
Klimaschutz und Digitalisierung hat mit der Pandemie nichts zu tun.
Das ist schon sehr weit weg. Es gibt für das Land Bremen, die das mit dem Bremenfonds auch gemacht haben, ein Rechtsgutachten eines Münchner Verfassungsrechts, das ist ein Koriot, der das auch sehr deutlich differenziert. Also man kann schon Maßnahmen auch über den Zeitraum der Jährlichkeit mitnehmen und kreditfinanzieren, wenn sie sehr klar den nachwirkungen, den greifbaren Nachwirkungen der Pandemie folgen oder darauf adressiert sind. Bei mittel- und langfristiger Geldverwendung wird es ein hoher Argumentationsaufwand, so schreibt er. Und das einfach mit dem Argument, wir haben ja eh ohnehin das Klimathema und die Transformation über Parken, das Geld. Ich meine, ich verstehe ja irgendwie, dass man alle möglichen Helden Notausgänge sucht. Und das ist ein Fenster als Helden Notausgang, es ist noch nicht mal eine Tür, es ist wirklich nur ein Fenster, um Mittel für die Investitionsbedarfe freizuschaufeln. Ich wollte noch die zwei anderen nennen. Das eine ist die Investitionsgesellschaftsidee, indem man die Autobahn GmbH oder die BIMA, die Immobiliengesellschaft des Bundes, das kann man auch alles machen. Das scheint mir aber der rechtlich unbedenklichere Teil zu sein. Denn wenn ein rechtlich selbstständiger Haushalt, der nicht Sondervermögen des Bundes ist und damit nicht zum Bundeshaushalt gehört, kein ausgelagerte Teil ist, dann kann man das außerhalb der Schuldenbremse dann faktisch tun.
So, also er sagt hier schon so ein bisschen neutral, dass kann man tun, wird ja auch gemacht, steht alles im Koalitionsvertrag drin. Also da ist der ganze Katalog ist als einmal verbrieft und kann jetzt irgendwie angewendet werden, muss dann aber auch angewendet werden. Also es sind noch sehr viele saure Äpfel, die Linda so beißen muss. Und er hat hier im Grunde so diesen, ja das ist so der Status quo. Im Grunde hätten wir gerne einen sauberen Haushalt, aber gut, nehmen wir mal Schattenhaushalte, dann hat er alle Ideen mal genannt, auch so wie du kommst, Investitionsding und dann entspinnst sich so dieses Gespräch. Denn wir haben ja von Südekum damals gelernt in diesem ein Gespräch, wo er noch mal für die Böckler Stiftung gesprochen hat und meinte, ja die Schuldenbremse ist eigentlich wirklich verrückt, weil sie ist ja so einseitig. Sie ist im Grunde so ein Misstrauen gegenüber der parlamentarischen Demokratie. Man traut den Parlamentariern nicht zu, vernünftige Entscheidungen zu treffen, also verbietet man sie ihnen qua Grundgesetz. So und mit dieser Idee im Hintergrund hören wir uns mal an, was Hüther ihr sagt.
In der Summe hat die Schuldenbremse schon ein Problem, weil sie das Investieren, das Erweitern des Kapitalstocks, auch das Erneuern des Kapitalstocks nicht als Verschuldungsgrund explizit sieht, sondern nur mit den 0, 35% für den Bund. So und das entspricht nicht den Bedarfen, die wir haben. Das ist nun mal so und deswegen muss man andere Lösungen finden. Es ist nur einfach so, Bert, es gibt keine Mehrheit, ohne die Union die Schuldenbremse zu verhelfen. Das Interessante wäre ja, wenn es eine Jamaika-Regierung gäbe, müsste die Union das Gleiche machen.
So, also man robbt sich langsam an die Realität ran. Ja, mit Jamaika müsste man auch die Schuldenbremse, weil wir haben ja mehr Bedarfe. Und das macht ja auch Sinn, über die 3, 5 plus irgendwas Prozent, die die Schuldenbremse noch zugesteht, mit so einer Klausel, die dann doch mal so ein bisschen öffnet, hier den Parlamentariern einfach zu erlauben, diesen Bedarf dann auch gerecht zu werden, also Politik zu machen.
Wir sind ja am Ende des Jahres, da kann man mal ein bisschen sentimental sein. Ist es nicht so furchtbar traurig, dass das jetzt auch ein Hüter erklärt und dass das jetzt durch die Bank einfach so gesehen wird, wie genau Investitionen dann aussehen und so. Das ist ja noch mal was ganz anderes. Aber dass diese Schuldenbremse eigentlich nicht mehr sein sollte, dass man die mit der Zweidrittelmehrheit abschaffen sollte oder in extremem Maße ausweiten könnte, dass man dafür keine parlamentarische Mehrheit, auch über die Frage, wer ist gerade Regierung, wer ist gerade Opposition hinausbekommt, dass man jetzt nicht mehr die AfD für irgendetwas ins Boot holen könnte. Und wenn es nur darum ging zu sagen, jetzt ist gerade Tag und heute Nacht ist Nacht, dann würde die AfD sagen, nee, es ist komplett umgekehrt. Aber dass man es nicht schafft, die anderen Parteien, und damit ist ja jetzt zum Beispiel die Union ganz stark gemeint, dass man sagt, guck mal, wir stehen doch jetzt hier vor den Aufgaben. Wir müssen doch jetzt einfach handlungsfähig werden, lass uns das doch jetzt machen. Und dann könnt ihr auch wieder richtig heftige Opposition machen, wenn ihr sagt, nee, da sollen aber gerade keine Windräder oder da soll besser Wasserkraft oder was auch immer sein. Das könnt ihr alles ja dann wieder durchspielen. Aber hier machen wir das doch mal gerade, genauso wie man gesagt hat, als es mit der Pandemie begann, zu sagen, so jetzt ziehen wir mal alle gerade an einem Strang, denn wir wollen ja die Bevölkerung schützen. Und dass man jetzt auch mal sagt, jetzt ziehen wir mal gerade an einem Strang, denn grundsätzlich brauchen wir dieses Geld. Und dann in diesen kleinen Dingen, welche Masken, wie, wann, wo, genauso wie der Pandemie, da kann man ja wieder streiten. Und so kann man es dann auch machen. Dass das nicht möglich ist, ist schon sehr traurig. Gerade dann, wo doch immer wieder dann bespuren wird, wie schön das doch jetzt war, wenn der neue Bundestag dann da entsteht. Ja, dass man in einer Demokratie so zusammenarbeitet und dass alle den anderen Respekt zollen und und und. Nee, das wäre auch mal eine Form des Respekts, wenn man jetzt einfach sagen würde, gut, wir wollen jetzt schon, dass die nächste Regierung eine Handlungsfähigkeit hat.
Genau. Und da wäre es doch richtig gut, wenn wir jetzt, so wie wir das ja sonst immer machen, sagen, Trosten hören, wenn wir zu der CDU-Fraktion hingehen können, dann sagen, Hüther hören. Ja. Denn jetzt kommt ein Clip, bei dem ich schreiben würde, das sollte sich mal der Hüther anhören. Nur es ist ja der Hüther, der das sagt. Wir sind jetzt also an dem Punkt, wo wir sagen können, liebe CDUler, hört euch doch mal den Hüther an. Der Hüther macht hier genau den richtigen Punkt. Und ich würde sagen, der Hüther argumentiert auch ein bisschen gegen sich selber, aber, das ist ja das Tolle, man kann ja seine Meinung auch irgendwann mal revidieren, spätestens dann, wenn es peinlich wird. Und an diesem Punkt sind wir jetzt, dass Hüther hier seine Meinung revidiert, weil es langsam auch peinlich wird. Und ich hoffe, mal gucken, 2021, neue Regierung, Lindner hat den ersten sauren Apfel, finde ich, ganz gut genommen und so, steckte ihm ein bisschen im Hals. Aber das ist so ein richtig schöner Vorlagen-Clip für, wie sollten wir ab 2021 über die Schuldenbremse und den deutschen Investitionsbedarf von Seiten des Staates diskutieren, am Beispiel Michael Hüther.
Das, was nur einfach dummerweise passiert ist, und da haben viele in unserer Zunft auch einen Beitrag geleistet, die Schuldenbremse zu überhöhen. Also man kriegt dann Kommentare dazu nach dem Motto, sie sind da sonst auch ordnungspolitisch sauber, wie kommen sie jetzt dazu, wenn die Schuldenbremse differenziert ist, als sei die Schuldenbremse der Kern der Idee einer ordnungspolitisch sauberen sozialen Marktwirtschaft. Ich meine, solide Finanzen, aber solide Finanzen heißt auch, Finanzen so bereitzustellen, dass das Wachstumspotenzial entwickelt werden kann und nicht, dass wir permanent unterinvestieren, ist halt genauso etwas, was zur Konstanz der Wirtschaftspolitik gehört, um ein Prinzip von Walter Eucken zu zitieren. Also da machen es sich viele sehr einfach und das finde ich auch total nervig, diese Debatte um die Schuldenbremse dann so zum ideologischen Kampf. Das bin ich auch nicht bereit zu machen.
Die Schuldenbremse ist doch ein Ausfluss eines tiefen Misstrauens gegenüber der Fähigkeit von Parlamenten, eine rationale, nachhaltige Finanzpolitik zu haben.
Ja, ganz erstaunlich.
Ganze Ideologie abgeräumt im Grunde von Michael Hüther und Bert Rürup.
Thomas Biebbricher schreibt es ja in seinem Buch Geistig-Moralische Wende, sein Buch über den Konservatismus. Was ist eigentlich dem Konservatismus der Union geblieben? Es scheint nur noch die Schuldenbremse zu sein, so als letzter ideologischer Kern und das macht er hier auch noch mal ganz deutlich. Ja, es ist nur noch eine rein ideologische Debatte. Wir klammern uns dann irgendwas fest, was dann auch, wenn man selbst bei Walter Eucken nachschaut, nicht mehr funktioniert. Das ist sehr, sehr schön, wie das denn hier aufgedröselt wird. Und das behalten wir uns im Hinterkopf mit der Verfassung, die dem Parlament misstraut. Denn wir kommen ja noch auf Chile zu sprechen.
Ja, also wir haben jetzt in der deutschen Diskussion hier, wie soll man sagen, die alten Player, die einmal die 180 Grad Wende gemacht haben, die wir uns immer gewünscht haben, jetzt ist sie da. Und die CDU hat jetzt einen neuen Chef, der immer noch als Wirtschaftsexperte gilt. Maurice Höfgen macht sich ja zurecht auf Zitter drüber lustig. Dem sollte die auch alle folgen. Also sowohl der Idee als auch Höfgen. Denn die CDU ist ja völlig blank. Das ist absolut peinlich, was die da abziehen. Und mal gucken, wie unter dieser Maßgabe das Bundesverfassungsgericht berät, sicher auch mit Experten vorher. Und die gehen natürlich auch die Liste durch. Wer regiert denn hier gerade? Die Wirtschaftsinstitute. Und dann kriegen sie Fratscher, jetzt Hüther. Und dann mal gucken, was Clemens Füß noch verbockt. Aber das ist schon mal eine sehr gute Vorbereitung für die Diskussionen, die da anstehen. Und der letzte Clip bezieht sich direkt auf dieses Investitionsgeschehen, das wir jetzt vor uns haben. Nämlich, dass die Grünen und der BDI sich da einig sind. Deutschland muss investieren. 250 Milliarden ist der Vorschlag des BDI. Damit im Schleppzau dessen die 680 aufwiegenden Privat-Milliarden, Privat-Unternehmer-Euros, mit entsprechender Rendite, Chancen, die dann auch nur gegeben werden kann, wenn der Staat das Fundament legt, finanziell. Auch darauf gehen sie hier ein.
Der Punkt ist ja durchaus richtig, den Christian Lindner immer macht. Nur die Komplementarität in diesem Transformationsprozess von staatlichen Vorleistungsinvestitionen in die Infrastruktur und privaten ist ja auch evident. Also die Privaten können ja nie ersetzen, was eine öffentliche Infrastrukturinvestition ist, außer ich beauftrage sie, aber dafür brauche ich auch öffentliches Geld. Und insofern ist das eigentlich kein Widerspruch. Aber man musste dann in jedem Fall überlegen, wie man durch eine Agenda der Deregulierung der steuerlichen Anreize, das will man ja auch machen, mit Superabschreibungen, also dass man mehr als 100 Prozent der Anschaffungsherstellungskosten abschreiben kann. Alles richtig, nur meine These ist, der Schub für die privaten Investitionen wird die Erwartungen nicht erfüllen, weil die Vorleistungen nicht erbracht werden. Ich meine, die Dinge hängen einfach. Wenn du durchs Land nicht durchkommst, weil jetzt auf der Sauerland-Linie eine Brücke einfach geschlossen werden muss und es gibt kaum Umfahrungsmöglichkeiten, aber dann ist dieses wie ein Kreislauf, der sich dann irgendwie um die Umgehungsfadel suchen muss, dann haben wir ein richtiges Problem. Und deswegen haben wir mit diesen Investitionslücken des Staates, die sich über mehrere Zeit insbesondere in der Infrastruktur aufgeteilt haben, einfach auch ein Problem für die privaten Akteure. Ich meine, die fahren quer durchs Land, die kommen nicht durch. Hier bei uns in Köln kommst du nicht über die Leverkusener Brücke, das sieht ja aus wie eine frühere Grenzanlage an der DDR.
Also ich bin jetzt Team Hüther.
Es ist wunderbar, das zu hören und es ist auch sehr dicht an der Wirklichkeit dran. Denn wir wissen zum Beispiel, auch wenn es fürs Klima problematisch ist, für das BIP, wenn man mal nur so argumentieren möchte, ist der Bausektor doch recht wichtig. Man muss es nicht übertreiben wie die Chinesen, aber er ist wichtig und er könnte viel besser funktionieren, wenn Handwerker einfach ihre Baustellen pünktlich erreichen könnten und nicht auf solchen Schleichwegen irgendwo rumfahren und im Schlauch stehen. Und das sind Investitionslücken, die sich direkt auf das BIP negativ auswirken. Daran kann keinem Gelegen sein.
Genau, also in der Hinsicht, das ist schon verrückt, was wir hier hören, das ist genau das Richtige. Es kommt zur richtigen Zeit, die Bundesregierung beginnt jetzt zu arbeiten. Wenn das so weitergeht, ist Lindner ein ganz einsamer Mann demnächst. Der dann selber gucken muss, wie er das mit seiner Wählerbasis noch klärt. Denn da wird er dann auch einfach erst wegmarginalisiert und dann kannibalisiert. Was natürlich ein Weg ist, den ich der FDP auch sehr wünsche. Also das ist Economic Challenges des Handelsblatt Research Institutes. Wer da reinhören möchte, den kann man natürlich kostenlos hören, den Podcast. Denn den sollte man auch breit treten. Also wenn ihr CDU-Abgeordnete kennt, sagt denen doch mal mehr Hüterhören, Leute. Wir müssen jetzt uns mal alle updaten.
Bin schon mal wieder auf dem Weg, aber ich bin schon mal wieder auf dem Weg, aber ich bin schon mal wieder auf dem Weg, aber ich bin schon mal wieder auf dem Weg, aber ich bin schon mal wieder auf dem Weg, aber ich bin schon mal wieder auf dem Weg, aber ich bin schon mal wieder auf dem Weg, aber ich bin schon mal wieder auf dem Weg, aber ich bin schon mal wieder auf dem Weg. Denn was wir eigentlich hier sehen können, ist, es hat sich ein linker Kandidat durchgesetzt. Wir werden jetzt gleich noch sehen, wie links, denn da werden natürlich auch sofort wieder Gespenster imaginiert. Und wir beginnen mal damit, dass wir einen Beitrag hören aus dem Deutschlandfunk. Da ist Anne Herberg, die wird da befragt zu den zwei Extremen.
Was sind denn die Ursachen dafür, dass jetzt zwei Extreme in die Stichwahl gehen?
Na, ich finde, man muss aufpassen mit diesem Bild der Extreme. Das wird ja sehr bemüht. Die Frage ist, ist wirklich ein Mensch wie Boris ein Extrem-Linker? Seine Ideen würde ich nun jetzt, wenn man das aus deutscher Sicht beurteilt, eher im Spektrum der Sozialdemokratie der Grünen verordnen.
Ja, wir werden ja nachher mal Boris hören. Und er ist sicherlich ein Kandidat, der absolut jetzt in diese Ampelkoalition passen würde. Was da jetzt immer so mit diesen zwei Extremen gemacht wird, ist natürlich mit dem Hufeisen zu arbeiten. Der andere Kandidat, der war allerdings sehr, sehr extrem. Wir kommen darauf auch noch zu sprechen. Blicken wir erstmal darauf, was im Mai in Chile vorgegangen ist. Chile hat eine Verfassung, die immer noch die ist, aus der Zeit der Pinochet-Diktatur. Das heißt, eine Verfassung, in der der Neoliberalismus, und da begann er ja, wo der Neoliberalismus eingeschrieben wurde in die Verfassung. Wir haben hier die Schuldenpreise, das ist auch so eine Sache, und wir hatten Massenproteste in Chile 2019, und als Folge dessen hat man sich entschieden, wir brauchen eine neue Verfassung, und hier wird berichtet, dass da Bürgerkonvent gebildet wird, und so weiter und so fort. Indigene Minderheiten müssen darin vorkommen, und die müssen jetzt an einer neuen Verfassung arbeiten, hier ein Tagesschaubericht vom Mai 2021.
Anstehen für eine Stimmabgabe, die Chile verändern wird, die Wahl des Verfassungskonvents. Gesucht werden 155 Bürger, die eine neue Verfassung schreiben sollen. Wir müssen die Fehler unserer bisherigen Verfassung beheben. Die stammt noch aus der Zeit von Diktator Augusto Pinochet. Darin wurde ein neoliberales Wirtschaftssystem festgeschrieben. So besitzen Unternehmer exklusive Wasserrechte, zum Beispiel für den Anbau und Export von Avocados. Gleichzeitig fehlt vielen Gemeinden Trinkwasser.
Das mit dem Wasser habe ich schon gehört. Das ist crazy. Erzähl uns mal von Wasser, während ich die Clips mache.
Ich werde erst mal was anderes erzählen. Erst mal ganz kurz zu diesem Gegenkandidat zu kommen, um mal zu sagen, das ist nicht zwei Extreme, die sich da gegenüberstanden, sondern es war ein guter Kandidat, ein vernünftiger Kandidat, der hat auch gewonnen. Und dann gab es einen absolut extremen Kandidat, der José Antonio Karst heißt und dieser ist Vater von neun Kindern. Sein Vater wiederum war Wehrmachtsoldat. Er unterstützt die Verfassungsänderung nicht. Er ist der Erste, der öffentlich auch sympathisiert mit Pinochet. Der sagte, nein, das war damals gut mit der Diktatur. Lasst euch da nichts einreden. Und es war keine Wahl zwischen den Extremen, sondern wir hatten da einen sehr, sehr extremen Kandidaten. Sehr beliebt natürlich bei Bolsonaro. Also jemand, der wirklich Chile jetzt auf einen sehr rechten Kurs gebracht hätte und der alle Errungenschaften, die ja in dem neoliberal-konservativ-Mitte-Chile der vergangenen Jahr, der auch diese Errungenschaften, die es da gibt in Sachen LGBTQ, in Sachen Frauenrechte und so weiter, der das zurückgedrängt hätte, in ganz erheblichem Maße. Und jetzt haben wir also da eine andere Situation. Es gab eine regelrechte Angst vor dem rechten Kandidaten. So hat Anne Herberg das geschildert.
Ich habe auch Menschen getroffen, die die Militärdiktatur unter Pinochet noch selbst erlebt haben. Und man spürt dort wirklich eine Angst vor dem Kandidat der Rechten, vor Kast. Sie sagen, er bedeutet ein Rückschritt in die Vergangenheit. Sie haben wirklich Angst, dass eroberte Rechte, Frauenrechte, Rechte der LGBTQ-Bewegung, dass das wieder eingebüßt wird unter Kast. Und für sie steht Kast auch ganz klar für jemand, der die Diktatur verteidigt.
Und jetzt hören wir, dass wir es mit einem Kandidaten zu tun haben, der die Diktatur verteidigt hat. Also das ist noch eine Grenzüberschreitung zu geben. Die anderen haben sich, sagen wir, mit der Vergangenheitarrangierung gesagt, wollen wir jetzt mal nicht, wir können jetzt hier nicht unsere Ahnen und unsere Großeltern und so, ja, da müssen wir jetzt mal gnädig sein. Und es war ja auch nicht alles schlecht so. Aber hier haben wir jemand, der wirklich sagt, nee, das war doch eigentlich gut. Und man kann sich natürlich dann vorstellen, wie die Überlebenden dieser Diktatur eine große Angst davor haben, wenn so einer kommt, dass die dann vielleicht nochmal eine zweite Diktatur erleben. Insofern ganz großer Befreiungsschlag, dass das jetzt nicht stattgefunden hat. Wie rechts dieser Kandidat ist, hören wir hier auch nochmal in einem Podcast von Owen Jones. Da wird Kast und die extreme Rechte, mit der er kooperiert hat, nochmal charakterisiert. Und inwiefern sich das vom bürgerlichen Lager unterscheidet.
Chile ist ein extrem rechter, wenn du magst, der Pro-Pinochet, aber den heutigen demokratischen System noch respektiert, ist fügt mit dem Zentraleich in Chile. Das ist der Standard-Establishment-Konservativ. Jose Antonio Cast war ein Establishment-Konservativ, der auf der rechten Seite des Chilean-Reichs war. Er war ein ziemlich extremer Figur, um mit zu beginnen.
Wie lange war Pinochet, wenn die jetzt immer noch so nacharbeiten, seine Frau ist irgendwann gestorben?
Genau, die ist jetzt mit 99 gestorben. Da sind ja auch viele dann auf die Straßen raus zum Tanzen und manche aber von diesen neuen Rechtsextremen, die trauern da. Und das ist aber schon diese neue Generation, die sozialisiert ist durch Reddit-Foren, durch YouTube und so weiter und so fort, die Steve Bannon-Interviews konsumiert und die jetzt sagt, uns droht die Gay-Diktatur oder was auch immer. Und diese Leute sitzen jetzt zum Teil aber im Parlament. Also ganz eindeutig hat Boric gewonnen, aber natürlich sind da auch viele Konservative eingezogen. Es war eine Stichwahl und das zeigt natürlich, dieses Land hat auch diese rechten Strömungen. Die brauchen natürlich, um wirkliche Mehrheiten zu haben, dann auch immer wieder eine bürgerlichere Politik. Die müssen irgendwie ja dann versuchen, über diese extrem mystischen Kreise hinauszukommen. Aber die sind inzwischen dann Teil des Parlaments. Und das wird natürlich die Arbeit auch sehr beschweren. Man kann sich denken, dass das alles nicht ganz leicht ist. Nun ist Boric, wie schon gesagt, jung. Und er ist anders sozialisiert, politisch. Nämlich nicht in erster Linie als Berufspolitiker, sondern erst einmal als Aktivist. Denn er war einer der wichtigen Köpfe der Studentenbewegung in Chile. Jetzt ist Studentenbewegung wirklich als eine große Bewegung dort zu sehen. Die Proteste waren etwas, was massenmedial richtig aufbereitet wurde. Was das Land in nachhaltige Diskussionen versetzt hat. Und auch diese Verfassungsänderung ist eigentlich auch ein Resultat dessen, was da angeschoben wurde. Und in dem Podcast von Owen Jones kommt jetzt auch ein Experte zu Wort, der das uns hier noch mal einordnet, wie wichtig eigentlich die Studentenbewegung für Chile ist.
Also, als Salvador Allende in den historischen Wahlkampf in 1970 den ersten demokratisch gewählten Marxisten Präsidenten der Welt, hat er seine Siegssprache vom Balkon der Fitch, das ist das Bild des Studentenbundes, weil die Studenten so wichtig waren, ist es schwierig, einen britischen Prime Minister zu vorstellen, die ihre Siegssprache von US-Offizieren zu geben.
Ja, Studenten sehr wichtig, Schüler auch sehr wichtig, denn man muss die Studentenbewegungen auch begreifen, als ein Resultat aus der Schülerbewegung, aus den Schülerprotesten aus dem Jahr 2006, also fünf Jahre früher.
Aber es ist wichtig, dass man sich daran erinnert, dass er eine Generation aus dem Jahr 2006 an die Sekundärschulen angetreten hat, das war etwas wie die Revolution der Penguen, weil die Schulformen in Chile schwarz und weiß sind, damit sie sich wie Penguen machen. Diese Generation hat in dem Jahr 2006 an den Sekundärschulen angetreten, dann hat sie in 2011 an die massive Universitätsproteste geübt und in 2019 sieht man sie wirklich in den Arbeitsmarkt gehen und dann der ganze Land erzielen. Es gibt eine Phrase, die oft gesagt wird, la generacion sin miedo, die Generation ohne Angst, die eine Beweise auf das Fakt ist, dass die Generation vor ihnen Angst hatte. Die Grundlage dafür war, dass sie brutal getraumert worden waren und die durch die krankste Diktatoren von Augusto Pinochet verletzte.
Bis hin zu was auch immer. Nur findet man immer nur sozusagen eine zeitliche Argumentationsgrundlage. Man muss dann schon in den deutschen Erbs zurückschauen, RAF und so weiter. Und da ist man sehr weit weg. Mehrere Generationen, mindestens zwei. Und ich frage mich dann immer, kann man das noch mal sachlich darstellen? Also nicht sachlich im Sinne von, dass es unsachlich wäre, sondern von der Zeitdimension auf die Sachdimension. Wo auf der Welt gibt es denn gerade Studentenproteste, die irgendwie nennenswert sind? In China ist es quasi unmöglich, in Europa ist es unerhört, da findet es nirgendwo statt. Also vielleicht so ein bisschen, wenn man sich Frankreich mal anschaut oder so, aber auch diese spanischen Sachen sind ja schon längst wieder vorbei. Chile scheint hier noch so das Nähelegendste zu sein. Dann kann man nämlich mal nachschauen, so in so einer vergleichenden Lehre, was ist denn die Grundlage? Welche Bedingungen müssen denn da sein? Und wenn man dann hört, ja, es gab halt, also wenn die sagen, wir sind die unängstliche Generation, und es gab aber eine, die Angst hatte, also das ist ja beispiellos für Deutschland, ja? Auf was sollte man sich jetzt hier beziehen? Also was stellt die Fridays for Future gerade anders? Also wie heben die sich ab von vorherigen Generationen, die es nicht geschafft haben, einen Schüler-Protest so zu machen, dass er irgendwie Erhöhung findet?
Vielleicht nicht mehr durch die Ironie. Also wir haben ja nicht mehr eine ironische Generation. Ich habe ja eben aus dem Roman vorgelesen vom Timon. Da haben wir ja noch eine ironische Generation, die ironisch jetzt auch mal auf den Kanzler pflegt oder auf die Jahre, auf Reformen und so weiter. Das ist jetzt sehr viel unironischer. Und daraus kann natürlich Protest erwachsen, aber es ist ein ganz anderer Erlebnis- und Erfahrungshintergrund, wenn dort Gewalt herrschte, wenn man nicht mehr Angst vor einer solchen Gewalt haben muss, einer Diktatur und kann dann als Generation ohne Angst sein. Es ist aber auch eine Generation ohne Perspektive, werden wir jetzt gleich sehen. Boric war also ein Kopf dieser Studentenproteste und hat auch Vorträge dazu gehalten, dann etwas später. Und ich habe dann mal bei YouTube gesehen, da gab es einen Vortrag von ihm 2015. Da erklärt er ein bisschen, wie das in Chile funktioniert hat, was er gemacht hat und so weiter. Und wir hören jetzt mal da rein, denn man könnte ja sagen, ja aber Chile hat doch eigentlich, stand doch ganz gut da. Chile gilt ja auch zum Beispiel als die Schweiz von Lateinamerika. Und man kann sich da vorstellen, Wirtschaftswachstum und so ist doch eigentlich alles gar nicht so schlecht gelaufen. Sagt auch Boric hier.
Die Unmöglichkeit zwischen jungen Chilen, mich selbst zum Beispiel, wurde von einer Differenz zwischen Erwartungen und Realität generiert. Von 1990 bis 2006 hat Chile die hohe Gewerkschaftspflicht pro Kavita über 4% und die Anzahl der Menschen, die unter der Poverty-Linie leben, ist von fast 40% bis 15%. Von 2005 bis 2005 waren 7 von 10 Chilis Studenten an der Universität die ersten in ihrer Familie, um eine höhere Bildung zu erreichen.
Ein scheinbarer Aufstieg, also ein Bildungsaufstieg, aber der nicht mehr dazu führt, dass man auch in mehr Wohlstand lebt. Wo liegt das Problem? Boric schildert es.
Und das segretierte ein teueres Bildungssystem, das sehr für viele Studenten für sehr schrecklich war. Ich studierte in der Hauptkommunikative in Chile, die Universidad de Chile.
An einer öffentlichen Universität 22.000 Dollar pro Jahr, um Jura zu studieren, sagt er, und das ist ein billiges Studium, also richtig teuer wird es, wenn man zum Beispiel Medizin studieren will, da ist man bei 40.000-50.000 Dollar, wird auch noch gesagt, also es sei nicht einmal in Amerika so schlimm. Chile ist das ungleichste Land der Welt laut OECD, war mir auch nicht in dieser Weise bekannt, habe es aber dann wirklich in mehreren Quellen gefunden, auch Financial Times hat es dann auch nochmal so zähleknirschend gesagt, na ja, er ist Linkerkandidat, aber ja, ist schon das ungleichste Land der Welt, was dann zur Folge hat.
We used to sit in the protest, tell me where you were born and I'll tell you where you're gonna die.
Ja, und dagegen gab es Protest und der war durchaus effektiv, aber Boric ist ja nun jetzt Politiker und jetzt sogar Präsident. Und da sagt er jetzt, wie er darüber denkt, Verhältnis von Aktivismus zur Politik.
So it's not enough with social movements. Social movements like remove the energy of a country, can remove the energy of a country. But if you want to make changes, you have to go into politics. You have to go into politics and be proud of it.
Wie konnte das denn passieren, dass der 2015 so einen Vortrag hält und dann fünf, sechs Jahre später plötzlich da zum Präsidenten gewählt wird? Wer hat denn dieses Drehbuch geschrieben?
Ja, er ist dann ungeheuer gefeiert worden. Man kann sich dann seine Dankesrede 30 Minuten lang ansehen. Ist leider nicht so gut übersetzt, aber wir sollten trotzdem mal kurz uns was anhören. Denn die Ansprache ist auch schon ganz interessant, wen er adressiert in der Dankesrede.
Und so sind ihre Eltern nicht allein in diesem Moment ihrer Leben.
Das gibt es in Deutschland nicht.
Dass die Kinder mal direkt angesprochen werden, die ihn ja gar nicht gewählt haben und dass man sagt, ja, Mütter und Väter sollen mehr Zeit für ihre Kinder haben. Das heißt, sie sollen weniger arbeiten.
Da kommen wir gleich darauf zurück, auf die deutschen Politiker und wie das ist mit den Kindern.
Also explizit dankt Boric den Frauen.
Ja, das ist natürlich, wir haben ja vorhin schon über Corona den Bogenschlag gemacht, dass Corona durch die Nichtherstellung der Endemie, weil wir hier dritte und vierte Booster brauchen, um nicht die ungeimpften zu, dass wir deswegen die Welt nicht impfen können und so weiter und das da niederschlägt in China mit Logistikketten, die unterbrochen werden. Wir dann wieder eine Inflation kriegen, weil irgendwelche Güter nicht geliefert werden und alles bricht so und sich zusammen. Und wo er das so sagt, das hatten wir auch ganz am Anfang in der Corona-Pandemie, als es plötzlich hieß, die Systemrelevanten. Was ja auch so ein Moment ist, wie wir es dann jetzt auch bei den Logistikketten und Inflationspreisen wieder erleben, dass bislang durch Selbstverständlichkeit externalisierte Kosten einfach mal bezahlt werden müssen. Man kann jetzt nicht mehr ausweichen auf irgendeinen anderen Zulieferer und der wird das dann schon über Menschenrechte, die er nicht einhält und so weiter machen mit dem Preis. Nee, es gibt halt jetzt nur noch einen Zulieferer. Den muss man jetzt hegen und pflegen und dann kostet das halt Geld. Und das ist ja hier auch. Und es wird die Deutschen auch noch extrem betreffen, wenn nämlich dieser ganze Pflegekräftemangel Erzieherinnen in den Kitas, ja wir denken immer es fehlen irgendwie 50.000 Pfleger in Deutschland, ja es fehlen aber auch 173.000 Menschen, die in Kindergärten auf Kinder aufpassen, die also dafür sorgen, dass Männer und Frauen, die eigentlich fürs Erwerbspotenzial zur Verfügung stehen sollten, jetzt plötzlich mit ihren Kindern und zwar im 1 zu 1-Betreuungsverhältnis zu Hause zu tun haben. So und das sind auch noch Kosten, die auf uns zukommen. Und die Politiker sollten jetzt auch schon mal anfangen, Dankes-Texte für die Frauen zu schreiben, die als Mütter dafür sorgen, dass Deutschland nicht komplett auseinanderfällt, weil ja 173.000 Erzieherinnen fehlen in Kindergärten. Und das hier so zu machen ist nicht nur vogue, sondern das ist wirklich sehr aufgeklärt.
Ganz genau, es geht hier nicht darum, so eine Pinkwashing-Kampagne zu fahren. Er grüßt hier auch ganz klar die Vertreter von Minderheiten, LGBTQ und so etwas. Wir hören uns da jetzt einen Clip an. Aber das ist auch eine Politik, die damit verbunden ist, die dann sagt, wir müssen alle sozial besser stellen. Es geht hier nicht darum, mal für sagen, ja wir hängen auch mal noch ein Fähnchen raus, um zu zeigen, dass wir tolerant sind, aber sonst ändern wir nichts.
Ja, also wenn wir in Deutschland mal aus einer, also überhaupt mal eine soziale Ungleichheitsdebatte kriegen, die dann über das Geld hinaus schaut, also Geld nur als das Medium. Daran kann man sehen, das sind die Symptome sozusagen. Dann wären wir auch einen großen Schritt weiter. Gut, in Chile, wenn das das ungleichste Land der Welt ist, wo nicht nur zwischen Bremen und Bayern zehn Prozent mehr Armut liegt oder 15 Prozent, sondern sozusagen wirklich viel, drängt das natürlich anders in so eine Debatte rein, aber ist für Deutschland auch total notwendig.
Ein nochmal ganz anderes patriarchales System, ein fester patriarchales System selbstverständlich und ganz andere Gewaltexzesse, die dort stattgefunden haben und mitunter auch noch stattfinden. Ich finde es ja ganz toll, dass das jetzt passiert ist. Also Henry Kissinger hat ja damals eingeleitet mit Nixon und anderen, dass man dort den sozialistischen Allende rausputzt und dann eine Militärdiktatur errichtet mit Chicago Boys und Co. im Rücken. Und Kissinger ist alt genug geworden, um jetzt noch mitzubekommen, dass man zwar keinen sozialistischen, aber doch immerhin einen sozialdemokratischen Präsidenten dort hat und dass sich da jetzt wirklich was verändert und dass die auch diese Verfassung ändern wollen. Und das bedeutet auch was für das Wachstum. Auch da kommt Boric in seiner Dankesrede kurz drauf zu sprechen. Ja, dieser Wachstumsfahrt ist nur dann gut. Wenn er auch entsprechend an allen vorbeigeht. Und wenn es nicht dann nur wieder an das oberste 1 Prozent geht, ist es also ein so ungleiches San Sebastian Pinera, der Präsident zuvor, der ja auch auf allen möglichen Panama und sonst welchen K-Pas immer wieder auftaucht, dieser Name, ist der zweitreichste Chile. Und auch gilt der General als einer der reichsten Politiker der Welt. Es sind glaube ich neun Familien in Chile, die das so unter sich eigentlich ausmachen. Und sich auch gegenseitig immer so heiraten, dass man das dann auch so weiter vererben kann. Es sind Dynastien, anders kann man es nicht beschreiben. Jetzt sieht man natürlich bei konservativen Plättern häufig, jetzt droht die Kapitalflucht. Im On John's Podcast wird dann gesagt, naja ganz so einfach wird das für das Kapital nicht sein, beziehungsweise die haben auch noch Gründe in Chile zu bleiben.
So ist es ein bisschen überblutend, dass die rischen Investoren all das Geld aus China holen. Das ist nicht der größte Konzern. Chile ist einer der weltweit die meisten China-dependente Ökonomien. Sie betreiben China wirklich für das Kauf ihres Koppers.
China ist in Lateinamerika sehr aktiv, wenn ich hier dann mit Kopf war. Aber wir wollen nicht nur immer zu den anderen blicken, sondern auch uns fragen, was bedeutet jetzt diese Wahl für uns? Beziehungsweise inwieweit kann jetzt die EU dafür sorgen, dass diese Regierung erfolgreich oder nicht erfolgreich ist? Denn man liest es ja dann gern, ist hoffnungsfroh gestartet, aber dann hat das irgendwie mit der Wirtschaft nicht geklappt und da denkt man immer, ja waren die einfach zu doof oder nicht willens oder so. Ne, da sind halt sehr starke ausländische Kräfte, die da mitwirken, Wirtschaftsinteressen und man hat es bei Chile ja nicht mit einer Supermacht zu tun, die einfach Regeln setzen kann, sondern sie muss vieles akzeptieren. Es gibt einen Freihandelsvertrag, der seit Jahr und Tag ausgehandelt wird zwischen Chile und der EU und da gibt es im Deutschland- Also noch ausgehandelt wird? Der ist noch nicht durch und man möchte ihn aber dazu kommen wir dann gleich natürlich jetzt noch ganz schnell durchbringen. Jedenfalls gibt es da einen Bericht aus dem Deutschlandfunk und es ist sowieso erstaunlich, wie toll die Sachen im Deutschlandfunk dann immer wieder sind. Also was, was solche Berichterstattung anbelangt. Wir haben ja immer bei Journalistenpreise werden ja immer irgendwie Leute ausgezeichnet, die irgendwie das eine tolle Porträt über Politik XY geschrieben haben. Ich würde ja gerne mal nur Journalistenpreise vergeben an Journalisten, die einfach ganz solide, richtig gute Arbeit abliefern und das in einer regelmäßigen Taktung. Und das ist hier bei Deutschlandfunk dann einfach der Fall, ob das jetzt Boddenberg mit einem Beitrag ist, Sophia Boddenberg oder Anne Herberg. Das ist die, die liefern das einfach mal in zehn Minuten. Was ist da los?
Gut, bevor wir uns das anhören. Dein Kumpel Ole hat einen Ausschnitt aus der Zeit heute Morgen getwittert. Vor seiner letzten Sendung als CDF-Moderator des Heuterschornals hat Klaus Kleber Sorge über den Zustand von Teilen des deutschen Journalismus geäußert. Und du hast ja gerade den Deutschlandfunk gelobt. Was ich oft höre von Moderatoren, insbesondere im Hörfunk, lässt mir die Hutschnur hochgehen, mit welcher Selbstverständlichkeit der Urteile abgegeben werden von Leuten, die sich erkennbar mit der Sache nie vertieft beschäftigt haben, sagt Kleber im Interview mit der Zeit.
Toll, aber Klaus Kleber kann doch nicht mal zum Wetter überleiten, ohne seine Meinung noch mitzumitteln. Wenn es doch einen Meinungshost gab, dann war das doch er auch immer gewesen, der, wenn er nur einen Namen ausspricht, dann weiß man doch schon, ob er den Politiker mag oder nicht.
Vor allem, wenn man Klaus Kleber transkribiert, weil man es ab und zu mal zitieren will, sieht man, der macht keinen ordentlichen Satz zu Ende. Das ist nur Gestolpere und Blödsinn.
Er sagt in diesem Zeitinterview, ich hatte nur die Headline irgendwo gelesen, auch wir brauchen weniger Ideologie im Journalismus. Also wenn die schon mit der Ideologiefreiheit kommen, dann wissen wir dann wirklich alles aus.
Da sich Klaus Kleber hier besonders den Hörfunk vornimmt, würde ich sagen, das sekundiert das, was du schon sagtest über den Deutschlandfunk. Wir können absolut zufrieden sein mit dieser Berichterstattung. Fahr ab, wie steht es um die EU und Chile.
Die Europäische Union ist der drittgrößte Handelspartner Chiles und der wichtigste Investor im Land. Gleichzeitig exportiert Chile hauptsächlich Avocados, Lachs, Wein, Kupfer und Lithium in die Europäische Union. Bereits seit 2003 sind Chile und Europäer durch eine Art lockeres Freihandelsabkommen miteinander verbunden. Das soll derzeit modernisiert und vertieft werden, um weitere Handelsschranken abzubauen.
Ja, klingt erst mal so, dass man sagt, da profitieren doch alle von.
Zum Glück ist es noch nicht fertig, kann man da nur sagen. Denn wir wissen von der Europäischen Union, das hat ja damals der Kern, der österreichische Kanzler gesagt. Die EU versucht ja jetzt immer, Freihandelsverträge neueren Typs zu machen, die quasi schon so viel Politik mit inkludieren, dass die Parlamente gar keine Rolle mehr spielen. Jetzt kann man sich da wieder selbst behaupten, das ist gut.
Was bisher bekannt ist, gibt der Verhandlungstext Investoren viele, aber der Bevölkerung wenige Rechte, sich gegen vermeintliche oder tatsächliche Vertragsverletzungen im Umweltbereich zu wehren. Sophia Boddenberg berichtet von dort.
Seit der Annahme des Abkommens vor 17 Jahren hat sich der Handel mehr als verdoppelt. Chile exportiert fast ausschließlich Rohstoffe aus dem Bergbau und Agrarerzeugnisse in die EU, wie zum Beispiel Kupfer, Lithium, Zellstoff, Avocados, Blaubeeren, Wein, Nüsse und Lachs. Die EU hingegen liefert verarbeitete Produkte, Fahrzeuge, Flugzeuge, Medikamente und chemische Produkte.
Der Clip geht 40 Sekunden und man hört schon raus, wie das so ein klassischer Rohstoff-Lieferant bloß nicht auf Augenhöhe kommen lassen.
Denn der Vertrag verstärke die Abhängigkeit der chilenischen Wirtschaft vom Rohstoff-Export.
Wir wollen keine koloniale Beziehung mit Europa. Dieses Abkommen erzeugt eine neokoloniale Beziehung. Die Europäische Union wird uns weiter verarbeitete Produkte, Maschinen und Autos liefern, während wir Rohstoffe exportieren.
Auch innerhalb Chiles sorgt diese Einseitigkeit für Probleme. Die wassaintensive Landwirtschaft verschärft Trockenperioden, Monokulturen und der Einsatz von Pflanzenschutzmitteln gefährden die Biodiversität. Bergbauunternehmen leiten giftige Abwässer in die Flüsse und ins Meer.
Das heißt, da wird unglaublich viel Dreck verursacht. Da werden Biodiversität und Dörfer und so weiter gerichtet, um uns hier ganz gut zu beliefern. Und jetzt versuchen wir, einen Vertrag auszuhandeln, bei dem das ja auch alles so bleibt oder eher noch besser wird für uns. Und Chile kann jetzt aber auch nicht einfach sagen, die machen wir nicht, weil sie jetzt auch aufgrund dieser langen Ausrichtung auf den Export von Rohstoffen natürlich sehr, sehr gebunden sind daran. Also die können jetzt nicht einfach sagen, da machen wir jetzt auch Hochindustrie ab sofort und machen das andere nicht mehr. Also diese Option besteht jetzt gar nicht. Und wir sehen also, welche Verantwortung jetzt die EU hat, wenn sie Green Deal und sowas ernst nimmt, bei einer solchen Aushandlung des Vertrags. Und es sieht nicht besonders gut aus. Und hier wird nochmal beschrieben, was das bedeutet, wenn man als Land so sehr auf den Export ausgerichtet ist von Rohstoffen.
Sepulveda nennt die Ausbeutung von Rohstoffen für den Export Extraktivismus.
Der Extraktivismus führt dazu, dass sich die Gemeinden verändern. Zum Beispiel werden für die industrielle Landwirtschaft Monokulturen angebaut. Alles, was produziert wird, ist für den Export. Damit verändert sich die ganze Region. Es müssen Straßen gebaut werden, Häfen.
Alles wird auf den Export ausgerichtet, während gleichzeitig die Dorfgemeinschaften zerstört werden.
Die traditionelle Landwirtschaft verschwindet.
Ja, manchmal denke ich, das ist so wie in Emmerichs Independence Day. Bisher halt so ein Land hältst du dich für ganz groß und dann kommt aber so ein Raumschiff durch die Wolken, zündet erstmal alles an, was du brauchst und im Grunde sind die nur da, um deine Rohstoffe zu holen. Aber die reden auch nie mit dir. Das findest du nur so raus durch die Blume irgendwie. Und du kannst, bevor es zu spät ist.
Und das ist sehr schön, du kannst mich mit ihnen auch nicht sprechen. Also wenn du jetzt sagst, ich will mich da mal melden, das geht so nicht. Hier, die haben jetzt da alles verwüstet. Es steht zwar Nachhaltigkeit im Vertrag und da sind so paar Dinge dann drin. Die sind aber nicht rechtlich bindend bzw. wenn man juristisch dagegen vorgehen will, hat man ein Problem.
Allerdings sieht das Nachhaltigkeitskapitel keinerlei Sanktionen vor, wenn dagegen verstoßen wird. Bei Konflikten soll lediglich ein Expertenpanel einberufen werden, um einen Empfehlungsbericht auszustellen. Ein schwaches Nachhaltigkeitskapitel ist unter EU-Parlamentariern und Umweltschützern auch einer der Hauptkritikpunkte an dem ähnlichen Mercosur-Abkommen, das die EU mit Argentinien, Paraguay, Uruguay und Brasilien schließen will, obwohl vor allem im Amazonas immer wieder die Wälder brennen.
Ja, also wie schon beim Klima, was ist bescheuerder? Den Klimawandel leugnen oder den Klimawandel anerkennen und trotzdem nichts machen? Und in den Freihandelsvertrag reinzuschreiben, ja, nehmen wir wahr, aber wir regeln ausdrücklich, dass wir dann nichts entscheiden. Das ist natürlich also frech.
Die Konzerne können da ein bisschen mehr tun.
Denn sie ermöglichen transnationalen Konzernen, Staaten auf Entschädigungszahlungen in Milliardenhöhe zu verklagen, wenn sie ihre Gewinne durch politische Entscheidungen beeinträchtigt sehen. Doch die sind zu erwarten. Chile befindet sich im politischen Umbruch. Monatelange Proteste haben dazu geführt, dass im nächsten Jahr eine neue Verfassung ausgearbeitet wird, die stärker auf sozialen Ausgleich setzt als die jetzige.
So was, wenn jetzt also eine Verfassung da kommt, die gewisse Formen der Extraktion nicht mehr möglich macht eigentlich. Ein Jurist kommt hier mal zu Wort.
Gus Van Harten ist Professor für Verwaltungsrecht an der York University und Experte in Investitionsrecht. Er meint, dass allein die Drohung einer Investorenklage dazu führen kann, dass Staaten weniger regulieren, beispielsweise im Umweltbereich.
Das wird normalerweise regulatory chill genannt, aber ich bezeichne es als eine Umgestaltung des Staates. Der staatliche Regierungsapparat wird umgestaltet zugunsten der ausländischen Investoren und zum Nachteil all derjenigen, deren Interessen von denen der Investoren abweichen.
Im Prinzip wird hier jetzt gerade an zwei Verfassungen geschrieben und die Frage ist, welche wird schneller fertig. Werden die jetzt mit ihrem Freihandelsvertrag früher fertig, dann greift er einfach und dann können die da sonst nichts mehr ändern. Oder werden die mit ihrer Verfassung schneller fertig, dass sie sagen, ja, nee, das verstößt aber gegen die Verfassung. Und es wundert jetzt nicht, wie die EU das Ganze vorantreibt, die Pointe legt auf der Hand.
EU-Botschafter de la Torre möchte die Freihandelsrunde so schnell wie möglich abschließen.
Wir möchten die Verhandlungen beenden, bevor ein sehr komplexer Wahlzyklus im Land beginnt, der es erschweren könnte, ein Abkommen wie dieses abzuschließen.
Denn die neue Verfassung und der Freihandelsvertrag wären womöglich nicht vereinbar. In Chile wird darüber diskutiert, natürliche Ressourcen wie Gas, Erze oder seltene Erden zu verstaatlichen. Auch wären schärfere Umweltgesetze fällig. Falls der erneuerte Freihandelsvertrag jedoch vorher steht, könnten europäische Investoren dann den chilenischen Staat verklagen.
Ja, da man als neue Exekutive das ja ein bisschen in der Hand hat zu steuern, nehme ich mal an, die wissen, was jetzt zu tun ist. Das ist echt immer so derselbe Klassiker. Vor allem diese Art, wo wir jetzt die letzten zwei Jahre ja doch in Europa so, ja wir sollten uns dann doch mal so weltweit anders verständigen. Wir haben auch gesehen, was es bedeutet, wenn Turbulenzen kommen, nicht nur Trump bringt irgendwie den Welthandel durcheinander, sondern dann auch noch Corona hinterher. Ob man das jetzt so ewig so weiter treiben will. Auf der anderen Seite, wir haben ja von Gerd Müller gehört, für uns arbeiten 50 Sklaven. Wir haben uns aber nie in die Frage gestellt, wo, eigentlich? Wir hören dann immer, in Bangladesch ist mal wieder eine Firma zusammengeknallt und dann waren 1000 Tote und so. Aber ja, das ist halt politische Landschaftspflege für die Sklaven da noch, die Orte zu schaffen, für uns arbeiten zu können.
Aber sehr gut, dass es da zumindest aufbereitet wird. Also das sind dann die Beiträge, die wirklich goldwert sind.
Kommen wir zurück zur europäischen und deutschen politischen Debatte, von der ich ja schon anmerkte an dieser Stelle. Manchmal ist sie mir ein bisschen zu doof. Ich höre mir dann trotzdem gerne an, was Habermas zu sagen hat. Aber es ändert nichts daran, dass es doof ist und stellt sich raus, nicht nur sind die funktionalen Analysen und Theorien immer gut in Anklang zu bringen, denn man muss sich ungefähr so verstellen, wenn aufgeklärte und abgeklärte Soziologen heute über Habermas reden, dann ist das wie über den Weihnachtsmann zu reden, für den kleine Kinder Wunschlisten schreiben. Man weiß dann, es gibt gar keinen Weihnachtsmann, die Briefe landen bei den Eltern und da stehen halt Wünsche drauf, ob die dann erfüllt werden. Das erklärt sich am 24.12. und nicht vorher, nur weil da Wünsche formuliert wurden. Und dann habe ich ja das letzte Mal diese Kritik gebracht. Ja, Habermas hat seine tolle Theorie sein ganzes Leben lang durchgepeitscht. Das macht er sie immer noch mit 90 Jahren. Hat sie ein bisschen revidiert, weil er dann gesehen hat, ach ja, das Internet in dem Text selbst, den man dann für 90 Euro kaufen kann, spielt aber die Realität, das Internet und wie man es verwendet, auch wieder keine Rolle, sondern da wird nur so über den Wolken drüber geflogen.
Da wird aber gesagt, jetzt vielleicht doch lieber die Massenmedien, die ich vorher kritisiert habe, weil das, was dort ist, noch im Zweifelsfall viel schlimmer ist. Und das ist natürlich auch dann in gewisser Weise nur noch sehr schwach. Also das ist ja dann, dann ist man ja schon sehr auf dem Rückzug. Also man kann natürlich sagen, ja, es wäre tatsächlich besser, bevor die Leute selbst in Facebook-Gruppen sich über Impfungen informieren, wäre es besser, sie würden einfach nur die Tagesschau gucken und da hören und machen, was gesagt wird. Aber das kann ja nicht alles sein, was man sich wünscht.
Genau, wollte man die Theorie mal wirklich durch die Wolkendecke auf den Boden der Tatsachen zurückholen, da sie selbst so unkonkret ist, würde ich sagen, wir könnten sie übersetzen in das Argument, bei TikTok ist so irre und durcheinander, dann doch lieber eine gute CDF-Krimiserie, die einfach eine dreiviertel Stunde lang gut abgehandelt wird. Und wer wollte mir widersprechen, wenn ich sage, das zentrale Aussage der Revision von Habermas über seine eigene Theorie, denn Habermas macht ja kein Angebot zu sagen, nee, das ist eigentlich klüger, das empirische Argument, weil das ist das empirische Argument, lieber Fernsehen als Internet. Stellt sich raus, ich habe das Philosophische Radio gehört und gedacht, ah ja, meine Kritik gab es ja schon damals live, als Habermas an seiner Theorie gearbeitet hat, gab es schon Widerspruch zu sagen, diese Güte-Kriterien oder wie sie auch immer heißen, Geltungsansprüche, das reicht nicht. Diese vier Dinge sind nicht allumfassend genug. Irgendwo muss noch mal jemand dazu sagen, dass es ja auch Unterhaltungsaspekte braucht, gerade in der politischen Debatte. Man kann nicht einfach nur alles so weit treiben, bis aufgrund von Müdigkeit, würde ich dann sagen, da Konsens hergestellt ist, weil dann fallen allen die Augen zu. Dann sagt man, ja gut, dann machen wir es halt so. Aber das ist ja kein Konsens. Und Joseph Früchtl, den ich nicht kannte, aber du wiederum.
Ja, der auch über Filme Interessantes geschrieben hat, über Heldenfigur und sowas. Also das ist schon ein guter Mann.
Ja, war im Philosophischen Radio bei Herrn Wiedek Wiebeke, oder wie er heißt, der mal sehr gutes Radio macht. Und sagt mir hier als Zuhörer, beruhige dich, Stefan. Deine Kritik gab es damals schon. Es ist die feministische Kritik, die schon sozusagen live Habermas gegenüber angebracht wurde.
Eine gewisse Unzufriedenheit mit dem, was wir in Frankfurt von Jürgen Habermas lernen durften, auch in Hinsicht der politischen Philosophie und seines Verständnisses von Kommunikation, von Verständigung. Es war in meiner Erinnerung und nach meiner Erfahrung war es ja auch hier wieder die feministische Kritik der 70er Jahre und dann der 80er, die in die Philosophie hinüber schwappte und einen erweiterten Begriff von Kommunikation vorstellte. Ein Begriff von Kommunikation, der nicht nur auf Argumenten ruht, sondern Rhetorik und performative Leistungen, körperlich mimische Elemente mit in den Kommunikationsbegriff aufnimmt, vor allem wenn es um Politik geht. Also diese feministische Stoßrichtung war eigentlich die erste, die uns innerhalb der Philosophie gesagt hat, da ist etwas nicht so, wie es sein sollte im Kommunikations- und Verständigungsbegriff, den Jürgen Habermas uns vorgibt. Und von daher ist es also auch innerhalb der Philosophie, hat sich das doch erheblich erweitert. Ich gebe Ihnen noch einen anderen Namen. Wir reden immer Jürgen Habermas jetzt die ganze Zeit. Und die konstruktive Kritik, die er feministisch erfahren hat, aber eine mindestens ebenso bekannte Protagonistin, wenn es um Gefühle und Vernunft und dann auch Politik geht, ist natürlich Martha Nussbaum, die seit vielen Jahren zu diesem Thema forscht und auf ihre Weise von einer anderen Richtung der Philosophie kommend, als Jürgen Habermas einen enorm produktiven Beitrag geleistet hat zu dieser Diskussion, in der wir uns jetzt auch gerade bewegen.
Ja, und um den Clip nicht zu lang zu machen, aber super interessant, er wird dann gefragt, was war denn der Beitrag von Nussbaum? Und sie sagt dann, also er referiert, ja, sie sagt halt nicht die Gefühle rausdrängen, sondern zähmen in der politischen Debatte. Lassen sie anerkennen, aber eben versuchen, es irgendwie in die entsprechenden Bahnen zu lenken. Und genau, das ist ja richtig. Der zweite Punkt, den man bei Früchtl hier noch gut hören kann, der, wie ich gerade nachschau, da auch schon etwas, aber nicht zu alt ist, also 67 Jahre. Man kann durchaus über die neuen digitalen Medien was sagen, ohne gleich zu zeigen, dass man die ganzen TikTok-Memes kennt, denn so kann man auch sich erden und als würdig in Debatten erweisen. Aber nein, man kann durchaus ein paar Argumente machen. Und ich hätte mir jetzt zum Beispiel gewünscht, dass Habermaß dann doch der Realität ein bisschen Anerkennung noch zukommen lässt. Der Früchtel macht es hier ganz gekonnt in der Diskussion.
Wir verschieben die Diskussion jetzt ein bisschen auf die technologische Ebene, auf die digitale technologische Ebene. Das ist, glaube ich, ein ganz eigener Punkt, der es wert ist, intensiv diskutiert zu werden. Weil die digitalen Medien nun in ihrer Art sowas, ja, eine Anonymität, gleichzeitig eine ungleiche Mischung von Anonymität und Intimität herstellen. Das haben wir ja bisher im politischen Diskurs gar nicht gekannt. Nicht die klassische, jetzt rufe ich nochmal Jürgen Habermas Studie auf über den Strukturwandel der Öffentlichkeit, die klassische bürgerliche Öffentlichkeit war ja getrennt zwischen Privatheit und Öffentlichkeit. Da trug man eben nicht die privaten Gefühle, die die Familie vor allem und den Freundeskreis kennenzulernen, in den politischen Raum.
So und jetzt gucken wir auf die neue Bundesregierung und nehmen beides, was er sagt, der ernst. Zum einen, es gibt seit Jahrzehnten die feministische Kritik an rein inhalt- und argumentations- getriebener politischer Debatte, nämlich zu sagen, schaut euch doch mal die Rahmenbedingungen der Debatte an und so weiter.
Performativität spielt eine Rolle. Also das ist ja etwas, was wir nun wirklich nicht wegleuchten können im Fernsehzeitalter. Oder wir haben ja History has begun gelesen, wenn noch mal geschildert wird, ja der Reagan hat sich schon als Filmstar auch gesehen, als er Präsident war. Und Trump sagt, macht es doch bitte so wie in meiner Reality-Sendung, filmt mich ja exakt so. Da ist es ganz explizit natürlich zu erleben, aber auch alles ist natürlich stark mit Performance verbunden. Und Performance und Rhetorik spielt auch eine Rolle, ob einem geglaubt wird oder nicht. Also die Art und Weise, wie jemand kommuniziert, spielt natürlich auch eine Rolle, wenn man dafür dann ein Publikum haben will, das einem glaubt oder das sagt, ja genau, das ist jetzt der richtige Aspekt. Also das ist ja auch interessant, wie jetzt bei der Virologen-Diskussion, welchem Virologen muss man glauben, wer ist mein Held? Natürlich auch ganz stark mit Performance-Elementen gearbeitet wird, beziehungsweise wo der eine zu viel performt, da ist das für die dann ein Anzeichen dafür, dass er es überhaupt nicht ernsthaft, kein richtiger Wissenschaftler ist. Und wer nur Wissenschaftler ist, aber nicht an die Menschen denkt und wird dann gesagt, das ist immer der Wissenschaftler, der nicht gut performen kann. Also diese ganzen Rollen spielen ganz klar eine Rolle. Und das wird tatsächlich in der Diskursethik von Haber-Maas ausgeklammert. Und es ist natürlich kein Zufall, dass es von der feministischen Seite aus kam. Denn Emotionen und Frauen ist ja ein Thema, das immer sehr stark in Misogyn thematisiert wurde. Wir kennen genau den Hysteriediskurs von Sigmund Freud der Psychoanalyse, wo gesagt wurde, die Frauen sind hysterisch oder so. Hildegard Knef brachte das immer auf den Punkt, wenn Männer brüllen, sind sie dynamisch, wenn Frauen brüllen, sind sie hysterisch. Also um das mal deutlich zu machen, wie diese diese Kluft da ist. Und deswegen kam von feministischer Seite also eine Kritik, dass man immer sagt, sind jetzt emotional oder so. Da wird dann gezeigt, dass das auch mit zur Kommunikation dazu gehört. Wenngleich ich da auch Nussbaum zustimmen würde. Es geht auch darum zu domestizieren. Nämlich, es kann nicht sein, dass wir jetzt die ganze Zeit losweinen und wir können nicht laufend weinen der Politiker und alles sehen und sagen, oder die erzählen uns erst mal, bevor sie die Pressekonferenz beginnen, wie sie sich fühlen und ich hatte ja einen Stress, ich habe viel zu viel getrunken gestern Abend, hatte Kopfschmerzen. Das geht alles nicht. Also da muss man sich domestizieren, da muss man sich zähmen, aber Emotionen spielen auch eine Rolle.
Genau, wir sind jetzt und das Fundament legen wir jetzt im postfaktischen, performativen Zeitalter, bei dem wir anerkennen, oh man, das Rad wurde noch mal ein Stück weiter gedreht, jetzt haben wir sogar noch Internet mit TikTok und so weiter. Und wir stellen fest, und das hat ja der Früchte hier grad so ziemlich spontan ganz gut auf den Punkt gebracht, Fernsehen, schön und gut, da wird einfach geskriptet, da macht Klaus Kleber seine schön vorgetragenen oder zumindest schön geskripteten und dann nicht so besonders gut vorgetragenen Moderationen und regt sich dann darüber auf, was im Radio schiefgeht angeblich. Und jetzt eine Stufe weiter, Internet. Wir haben eine ganz besondere Verschränkung und die kann jeder Twitter-Nutzer, kennt die, von Anonymität und Intimität. Wir kennen die Leute gar nicht, von denen wir aber feststellen, oh das hat aber jetzt in dieser Sekunde mega Relevanz, dass zum Beispiel irgendwelche Twitter-User über, vor zehn Jahren ist mein Sohn gestorben, heute erinnere ich immer noch und ihr sollt mit erinnern und da stehen da 5000 Pfaffs runter und man fragt die so, ok, befasse ich mich auch kurz damit. Ich kenne die Person gar nicht, aber ja, also diese Mischung aus Anonymität und Intimität spielt jetzt eine ganz große Rolle, auch im politischen Diskurs. Es ist nicht sozusagen der auf den Konsens zielende, inhaltsgetriebene Diskurs oder irgendwas, wir pauken gerade nicht alle den Koalitionsvertrag durch, sondern wir erregen uns über die Sachen, die wir da halt so sehen. Und da finde ich, ist es dann wieder besonders, es klingt so flapsig, wenn man den einfach zuhört, aber es ist eben diese besondere abgeklärte, aufgeklärte Haltung, wenn wir hier zuhören, wie Serdar So Muncu mit Florian Schröder über Annalena Baerbock spricht. Und man kann jetzt in diesem Falle vorbereitet noch sagen, Serdar So Muncu hat Annalena Baerbock so richtig abgrundtief gehasst bisher in dem Podcast, vor allem ihre Wahlkampfführung und so weiter. Jetzt ist sie aber eine Woche lang Außenministerin gewesen und plötzlich ist Serdar So Muncu diese Ansicht.
Ich wollte dir als Friedensangebot machen, dass ich Annalena Baerbock mittlerweile super finde. Find ich super.
Wie kommt's? Wie kommt's? Die frage ich dir jetzt im Raum. Und wir können jetzt überlegen, macht Serdar So Muncu jetzt ein Argument hinsichtlich irgendwelcher Inhaltlichen, eine Ausgestaltung und so weiter und so fort? Oder ist es eine rein performative Angelegenheit hier noch mal sozusagen Fernseher erleben, Medien erleben, Twitter erleben, Instagram erleben, Annalena Berber vor Kamera erleben, einfach zu spiegeln?
Eine super Außenministerin. Ich bin total geflasht von ihr. Kanzlerin hätte ich nicht gewollt. Ja, Kanzlerin hätte ich gesagt, will ich nicht. Aber Außenministerin, top. Super repräsentiert ein Deutschland, hinter dem ich voll und ganz stehe, macht eine gute Figur. Habe ich nicht erwartet, dass sie so schnell in dieses Amt findet. Und ich finde, ohne diese Machtoption Kanzlerin zu sein, hat sie sich gefunden. Ich bin begeistert von ihr.
Ja, ja, die ist so euphorisch bin ich jetzt nicht. Aber man spürt, sie kommt vom Völkerrecht. Das muss man einfach sagen.
Die beiden steigern sich ja immer so rein in die Sachen. Dadurch ist es immer super spontan, wie sie es dann sagen. Weswegen wir hier noch mal eine Minute lang zuhören, wie sich dieses Gespräch entfaltet.
Ja, ich finde es auch ganz positiv. Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass sie da ihre Kleider und die richtigen Kleider gefunden hat. Das scheint zu passen. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass sie als Außenministerin viel besser ist, als sie als Kanzlerin gewesen wäre. Das ist wirklich ihr Metier, mit dem sie sich ja schon viel länger auseinandergesetzt hat. Da könnte sie gut reinfinden. Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass wir da eine Überraschung erleben werden und dass sie da sich freischwimmt mit der Zeit.
Ja, die hat was total Entwaffnendes an sich. Die ist charmant, die geht mit den Leuten gut um. Also jetzt die ersten Bilder, die man gesehen hat. Sie sagt schöne Dinge, ich fand die Rede schön, die sie gehalten hat in Polen. Also ich traue ihr zu, eine der besten Außenministerinnen zu werden, die wir in diesem Land hatten.
Du bist halt ein bisschen borderline, bist du schon. Entweder ganz scheiße oder total großartig. Das mag ich schon.
Manchmal verliebt man sich ja auch in Frauen, die man vorher nicht mochte.
So ist das jetzt unangebrachte politische Diskussion, die man am liebsten an den Rand drängt, weil wir wollen ja ernsthaft über die Außenpolitik, zum Beispiel in Polen. Sie macht einen Antritt zu Besuch in Polen. Wir wissen, wie das Verhältnis in Polen ist. Sie bekommt erst mal einen 20-Minuten-Vortrag vom polnischen Amtskollege, der ihr dann sagt, wir wollen aber Reparationsleistung für den Zweiten Weltkrieg noch so weiter haben. Und was in Deutschland ankommt, ist dann der Seda Semuncu, der ein sehr politischer Mensch ist, in Podcasts einfach sagt, oh, ich fand die total schön, die Rede, die sie da gehalten hat. Also geht das sozusagen über oder müssen wir hier noch ein bisschen Habermas gelten lassen?
Na ja, gut, wofür ist eigentlich eine Außenministerin da? Sie repräsentiert und sie macht ja dort diese Rede nicht, weil sie jetzt mal dem polnischen Kollegen was mitteilen will. Das kann sie ja auf allen anderen Wegen. Dafür braucht man nicht eine Pressekonferenz. Also es ist eigentlich eine Presse- und Performancekonferenz. Und deswegen ist das Beurteilen von Performance. Und sogar, ich gehe so weit wie die beiden Herren, von Kleidung nicht etwas, was man jetzt erst einmal ablehnen sollte. Denn das gehört zu dem politischen Spiel hinzu. Und auch selbst ein Jürgen Habermas sagt ja, alles, was wir über Politik, Gesellschaft und so weiter erfahren, erfahren wir vermittelt über Massenmedien. Anders geht das gar nicht. Ich kann nicht hier rübergehen zu deiner Nachbarin und sagen, was ist eigentlich in der Gesellschaft los, sondern ich muss halt die Tagesschau gucken oder Radio hören oder sonst was machen. Und sie auch. Und ganz genau, sie auch. Und deswegen spielen diese performativen Kriterien eine Rolle. Und spielen sie übrigens auch bei einem Mann eine Rolle. Also man kann jetzt nicht jetzt gar nicht sagen, jetzt reden die auch noch etwa über das Kleid. Man kann durchaus auch sagen, also erst mal kann man auch Komplimente machen, dass jemand einen guten Kleidungsstil hat. Und das würde ich hier auch unterschreiben. Und man würde aber auch gleichzeitig ja bei Männern kritisieren, wenn sie nicht so toll angezogen sind. Und da ist ja Heiko Maas das beste Beispiel für gewesen, dass das performativ nicht so auf der Höhe gewesen ist. Wenngleich ich diese Euphorie nicht teilen kann, weil ich tatsächlich jetzt auch unter Performance-Gesichtspunkten nicht sehe, wo Baerbock eine gute Rednerin ist. Also das ist einfach, dass ich mich eher wundere, warum das nicht durch ein bisschen Training, Coaching, was sie da so falsch macht, gerade Konsonanten zum Beispiel weglässt, warum man das nicht ausgebügelt hat. Das leuchtet mir nicht ein, weil das ist ja alles machbar.
Siehst du, da verfangen wir uns auch schon wieder, denn wenn du das Angebot machst, sie so zu beobachten, sage ich, ich finde, sie ist zu viel gecoacht, sagt man zwar immer gerne, aber sie redet zu laut. Also in Gesprächen, in diesem prosieben Interview damals, das sie gemacht hat, das war ein unglaubliches Rum-Geschrei, wo ich dachte, sie muss gar nicht so laut brüllen. Die Sätze können auch einfach mal so Geltung gewinnen, aber sie gewinnen ihre Geltung eben über die Performance. In diese Falle tappen wir hier und sie auch, denn so wie Serdar Zomuncu hier einfach sehr ehrlich darüber spricht, der IHC hat es im Fernsehen jetzt gesehen, war überrascht und hat sich gleich verliebt. Also damit muss man jetzt einfach leben, das ist die Realität, in der man dann auch die Wahlen wieder gewinnt. In vier Jahren, da kann man noch so sehr hoffen, dass irgendwer sich für irgendwas interessiert. Aber nein, am Ende sind das die Gütekriterien, die wir miteinander abwägen.
Also meine Großmutter hatte sich wahnsinnig damals verwundert, dass Edmund Stoiber regelmäßig auf die Sonnenbank ging. Also das hat sie als Mann regelmäßig auf die Sonnenbank. Also das gefällt ihr gar nicht.
Die haben doch große Balkone in Beiden.
Das war für sie ein wichtiges Kriterium, also auch wieder Performance.
Ja, so und wer kann noch besser Performance als Annalena Baerbock? Natürlich Robert Habeck. Er hat ja seinen Performance-Film bekommen. Hast du den gesehen von Feldenkirchen? Ganz merkwürdig, ich sag's mal so. Wir machen jetzt einen Brückenschlag in diesem Habeck-Film von Feldenkirchen, der in der ARDI lief. Kam auch Baerbock kurz vor. Denn Robert Habeck hat wieder eine Schose abgezogen und gesagt, zur Bundespressekonferenz kann ich doch laufen. Sie sind nur 600 Meter. Während Annalena Baerbock hohe Schuhe anhatte, weshalb sie nicht laufen konnte und den Dienstwagen nahm, also er da war, bevor er dann da war, begleitet von Kamerall. Team Obenfeldenkirchen und sie begegnen dann Annalena Baerbock, die um die Ecke auf die beiden wartet, weil sie wieder nicht alleine reingehen und so weiter. Und wird angesprochen auf die Frage, was sie sich für sich von der Bundespressekonferenz, also dem Auftritt, dort erhofft.
Er geht zu Fuß, sie wird die 650 Meter gefahren, wegen der hohen Schuhe. Treffen sollen sie sich irgendwo um die Ecke. Was haben Sie sich vorgenommen für die PK jetzt gerade?
Das finde ich sehr sympathisch.
Ja, das ist einfach super. Das ist nicht ehrlich.
Sehr sympathisch. Und ich weiß ja gar nicht, was ich von dem Kommentar halten soll. Ja, wegen der hohen Schuhe und so. Ja klar, wenn man eine hohe Schuhe hat, dann rennt man nicht mal schnell noch 600 Meter durch die Gegend.
Genau, also zufällig sehen wir beide gerade hier im Stream nicht, hier die beiden. Und Annalena Baerbock, blaues Kostüm, sie wirkt sehr aufgeweckt, steht da als rum. Habeck kommt, sie wird gefragt und sagt dann, sie eine gute Figur machen. Warum sind die Journalisten dort? Und wir haben ja eben schon festgestellt, wenn dort Ulrich Schneider kommt und über die Armut in Deutschland, also über 13 Millionen Menschen spricht, denen es nicht gut geht, sitzen da drei Leute und zwei stellen eine Frage und dann ist vorbei nach 23 Minuten. Hier ist das anders, da kommen sehr viele, um die beiden in der Bundespressekonferenz zu sehen. Warum? Wegen den Antworten und den Inhalten? Natürlich nicht. Alle teilen ihren Anspruch, nur für sie ist es Risiko. Es liegt nämlich in ihrer Entscheidungsgewalt. Sie kann jetzt einfach gut performen. Sie will gut aussehen. Es ist genau die richtige Antwort. Was erhoffen sich die Journalisten, die dort sind? Na ja, dass sie halt, sie wollen sie scheitern sehen im Grunde. Also dieses Spiel läuft jetzt sozusagen ab. Und wir haben hier gerade schon gesehen, Robert Habeck sitzt an einem großen runden Tisch ihm fällt ein Kirchen gegenüber. Und für uns hat man den Film hinter Habeck noch mal projiziert, sodass wir den Film sehen können, während wir gleichzeitig Robert Habeck zuschauen können, wie er den Film über sich selber im Fernsehen sieht, was wir dann im Fernsehen sehen. Also mehr Anti-Haber-Maß geht hier gar nicht. Weiß ich nicht, was das ist.
Das ist eigentlich schon Jean Baudrillard, dass man nur noch Politik simuliert und sich ja noch bei der Simulation zuguckt.
Also es ist wirklich grandios. Naja, jetzt geht es jedenfalls um Habeck in diesem Film. Und was heißt eigentlich Politik machen?
Also man fragt sich ja manchmal, wie kannst du nur so doof sein, regieren zu wollen? Ich meine, das ist ja nun wirklich eine fürchterliche Lage. Corona und die Aufgaben selbst, ich höre von meinen Dirigenten, die das Ministerium sind, sind so riesengroß und es wird so viel Ärger geben. Und ich werde meine Familie so wenig sehen. Und ich werde so ins Fahrtenkreuz geraten, dass man wirklich denkt, äh, was machst du doch eigentlich?
Ja, ein bisschen schwer zu verstehen. FFP2-Maske im Dienstwagen und dann noch genuschelt und so weiter. Aber er beginnt mit, er ist doch eigentlich irre, jetzt regieren zu wollen. Und vor allem, dann lasse ich ja meine Familie im Stich. Also er macht schon den Bogen von Politik, das, was uns alle, also auch mich betrifft, was betrifft mich am meisten, aber Familie. Und macht aber gleich die Unterscheidung, ne, gute Politik heißt wenig Familie. Also für mich wenig Familie. Ich kann nur zwischen Politik und Familie mich entscheiden, wo ich schon wieder denke, ne, also so weit sollten wir das ganze Performance-Ding jetzt trimmen, zu sagen, wenn wir gut performen wollen, geht das nicht ohne, ich sag mal, Oxytocin-Rückhalt. Also man kann sich mit Dopamin zupeitschen, indem man sich einfach vor einer Bundespreisekonferenz mit Inhalten und so weiter über Bildschirme vermittelt. Aber das Kuschelhormon Oxytocin, das vor allem über Hautberührung und so weiter, das spielt auch eine maßgebende Rolle. Und das wird hier einfach rausgedrängt. Das ist natürlich bei Corona, wir sind alle darauf trainiert, jetzt auf Oxytocin-Entzug. Aber wenn ich dann sowas sehe, mach ich mir Performance-Gedanken und frag mich, wie weit will man es treiben, Politik auf eine Art und Weise zu machen, die ich nicht akzeptiere. Also ich wäre total dafür, dass, wenn wir eine Familienministerin haben, die vier Kinder hat, Jahrgang 80, warum sollte die nicht am Wochenende frei haben für ihre Kinder, zwei Tage, so wie jeder normale Mensch auch. Darum geht es doch. Wenn die Politik mal erkämpft hat, dass man eine 40-Stunden-Woche hat und eine 5-Tage-Woche, warum gilt das dann plötzlich nicht für die Politik, die ja sowas für uns erkämpft?
Ich frage mich immer, ob das in diesen Ämtern möglich ist. Klar gibt es jetzt Politiker, die einfach eine Aufmerksamkeitsgeilheit haben und deswegen auch jedes Interview noch annehmen und überall sich hinkutschieren lassen, nur weil es da noch mal einen Auftritt gibt. Aber ich glaube, es gibt ja einfach auch sehr viel zu tun tatsächlich. Ich glaube, dass man manche Berufe nicht mit einer 40-Stunden-Woche machen kann. Das sind aber auch passion-driven Berufe. Das ist ja genau das, was er jetzt hier gerade schildert. Das gibt es ja entsprechend auch von irgendwelchen Popstars, die sagen, wenn ich einen Auftritt am Abend habe, ist mir den ganzen Tag schlecht. Ich kann nichts essen. Ich habe Lampenfieber und Zitter. Aber wenn ich auf der Bühne stehe, ist dann gut. Ist alles toll. Und dann weiß ich wieder, warum ich es mache. Und es wird auch diese Momente geben, da weiß er, warum er es macht. Und ich glaube, da ja bei solchen extremen Berufen, genauso auch wie der Spitzensportler, sich niemals so ernähren wird können wie ich. So ist es beim Politiker auch, dass man da wahrscheinlich nicht alles haben kann.
Und dem würde ich genau widersprechen. Denn das liegt nahe, das so zu sehen. Aber wenn man einmal die großen Wirtschaftsbosser und die Politiker und auch die journalistischen Koryphäen erlebt hat, wie weit sie das Prinzip des Delegierens treiben können und auch dürfen, fragt man sich, warum überhaupt noch jemand arbeitet. Also im Sinne von nicht nur Beschlussvorlagen absegnen und so weiter. Denn du kannst es ins Unendliche treiben. Als Bundesminister kannst du 100 Leute vor die Verantwortung überlasten, ihr verhindert jetzt den Krieg und ich gehe ins Wochenende. Und wenn die nicht liefern, ist halt Krieg. Aber niemand käme danach zu dir und sagt, du hast aber nicht so weiter. Das sind nämlich alles Performance-Sachen. Wenn Politiker heute in die Enge getrieben werden, dann, weil das Medium, Fernsehen, Twitter, wir und so weiter, das schafft. Niemand muss an einem Buch scheitern, das wir im Salon gelesen haben und das ich ziemlich gut finde, nur weil da ein paar Fußnoten nicht gemacht worden. Wir wissen alle, wie Bücher geschrieben werden.
Normalerweise allein.
Normalerweise allein, aber nicht diese Politiker-Bücher.
Ja, genau. Also, ich meine, das Politiker-Bücher, wer sie liest, ist sowieso, glaub ich, in meinen Augen selbst schuld. Aber dass die zusammengeklopft werden, ist klar. Aber ich glaube, dann ist es eher eine Sache, ja, was kann man delegieren? Und wollen die sich vielleicht auch gar nicht abkömmlich machen? Wir haben das ja schon mal, glaube ich, gehabt, diese Anekdote, Chefredakteur der New York Times oder was, ist nie in Urlaub gefahren, weil er sagte, ich bin ja hier nicht zu ersetzen. Nein, man fährt natürlich nicht in den Urlaub, weil man sonst sehen würde, oh Gott, das geht ja auch ohne mich.
Richtig. Und das ist die große Gefahr in der Politik, dass du nicht wiedergewählt wirst, wenn alle feststellen, ja, also den können wir einfach austauschen. Der Apparat funktioniert, das Haus ist gut bestellt. Einfach zack, zack. So, und das darf natürlich nicht sein. Dieser Eindruck darf nie aufkommen. Und dieses, du hast eben gesagt, Passion getrieben. Diese Leidenschaftlichkeit, die da drin steckt. Und zwar vor allem für dieses mediale Spiel, das Politik bedeutet. Das macht diesen großen Unterschied. Kein Politiker ist so raffiniert, dass er unverzichtbar ist. Sondern am Ende ist gute Politik immer das gute Management des Hauses. So, wenn das Haus funktioniert, funktioniert es. Wir alle kennen die Journalisten, die im Sommer immer mal drei Wochen nicht da sind, weil sie einfach ein gutes Haus haben. Und es ist halt drei Wochen nicht da. Und wenn dann irgendwas nicht funktioniert, also irgendein erster Stellvertreter ist schon da, den man dann zur Verantwortung ziehen kann. Und so funktionieren diese Bundesministerien auf jeden Fall.
In der Politik gilt es wahrscheinlich in der Kunst, glaube ich, das jetzt nicht oder im Spitzensport. Also ich glaube, es gibt einfach, also wer jetzt sich entscheidet, Opernsänger zu werden, wird kein normales Familienleben führen können. Das ist einfach so. Aber das muss man ja auch nicht. Also man kann sich ja auch für das eine oder andere entscheiden. Also ich kann ja auch nicht sagen, ich hätte gerne fünf Kinder, würde aber gerne so leben als wäre ich allein. Das geht auch nicht.
Genau. Also in der Kunst, wenn man nicht, wie hieß der Deutsche, der dann irgendwann hier, der auch die Kanzlerporträts eins mitgemalt hat und dann nur noch delegierte.
Imendorf.
Imendorf, richtig. Oder man hat so Rembrandt, der das Atelier macht, und man steht nur noch da und delegiert. In der Politik, also ich würde sagen, das, was wir Politikern andichten mit, müssen so immer zur Verfügung stehen und so weiter, das sind diese Stabsstellen in der Politik. Da kannst du wirklich nicht einfach in den Urlaub fahren, weil da musst du einfach regeln. Und die organisieren noch das Haus. Aber als Politiker bist du genau, also als Minister, bist du genau diese eine Etage drüber, wo du es dir erlauben darfst. Und das ist eben der große Unterschied zwischen kulturellen Koryphäen, die dann einfach, der Auftritt muss halt abends stattfinden, und zwar nicht zu Hause, sondern irgendwo. Das ist eben anders, wenn du Familienpolitik machst. Dann machst du nämlich Familienpolitik. Und dann kannst du nicht deine eigene Familie, die du ja, und sie hat ja eine, die deutsche neue, die eine Spiegel, also die kann da nicht ihre Familie im Stich lassen. Das ist bei Annalena Baerbock auch. Bei Annalena Baerbock ist zum Beispiel der Mann jetzt nicht mehr berufstätig, sondern er kümmert sich um die Familie. Das ist einfach eine Organisationsform, die man entfinden kann. Und bei Habeck ist das ganz merkwürdig, denn Habeck ist so krass Performance getrieben, dass man sich, also ich mir echt Sorgen mache, ob wir hier gut regiert werden. Inhaltlich muss ich sagen, Habeck hat sich einen Stab zusammengestellt. Mit Giegolt und Franziska Brandner und so weiter, die wir hier alle schon gelobt haben, weil sie auch am Bundestag tolle reden und so weiter. Bisher nie groß auffällig. Massenmedial, aber da einfach genau in der richtigen Stelle. Also Habeck hat sich eigentlich insbesondere jetzt im Wirtschaftsministerium zusammengebaut auf dieser politischen Leitungsebene, wo man sagt, die können das wahnsinnig gut ohne dich, Herr Philosoph. Trotzdem zieht er hier so eine Schoße ab. Und dieser Ausschnitt, den bestimmt viele schon gesehen haben, der ist auch ein bisschen traurig.
Heute Morgen habe ich Müsli mit Wasser gegessen, ohne Scheiß, weil ich, weil die, ich hatte keine Milch mehr und auch keine Hafermilch und gar nichts mehr.
Ist ihre Frau nicht da?
Nee, die ist, die will auch nicht zu gucken, wie ich, wie ich untergehe.
Ja, kann ich alles überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen. Also du hast eben vom Delegieren gesprochen, der Mann ist ja nicht arm, der hat ja alle Möglichkeiten, der ist da in Berlin und wenn einem das ja alles zu viel wird und man das in der Wohnung nicht geregelt bekommt, dann geht man halt dann mal während dieser heißen Phase ein Hotel. Das kann er sich ja leisten. Also da weiß ich gar nicht, was los ist. Das ist ja vollkommener Unsinn. Also wenn man dann sagt, ich habe jetzt gar nicht gekocht gekriegt oder so. Warum soll der auch kochen?
Habeck hat einen Fahrer, dessen Dienstvertrag ist wie ein Butler-Madlon-Organisiert. Der kann ihn los schicken und ihm Müsli bringen lassen. Egal woher.
Also das ist einfach Show. Das ist auch eine Show, die ich nicht akzeptiere.
Ganz genau.
Ich kann jeden verstehen, der irgendwie sagt, ich muss jetzt nochmal los. Ich habe die falsche Krawattenfarbe heute. Lindner ist ja da immer sehr perfekt hergerichtet. Aber das hier ist reine Show, zu sagen, mir geht es so wahnsinnig schlecht. Und ist es nicht unglaublich.
Genau. Und jetzt hast du genau den richtigen Satz gesagt, das ist eine Show, die du aber nicht akzeptierst. Und damit schließt sich der Bogen zu dem feministischen Argumentation gegen diese Habermasche, irgendwas mit Argumentation und so weiter. Die Emotion spielt eine Rolle. Aber sie wird auf eine Art und Weise, von Habeck hier domestiziert, wie du vorhin sagtest, oder die Performance wird aber in einer Art und Weise vorgespielt, wie du es nicht akzeptieren kannst und ich auch nicht. Und sie ist durchschaubar verlogen. Denn so wie er sich hier schmückt mit, ich bin so überarbeitet, ich musste so krass Koalitionsvertrag machen, ich musste mein Müsli mit Wasser essen. Und das sieht man häufiger bei Männern, die ihre Kinder verwahrlos zurücklassen. Wenn sie dann auf ihre Kinder angesprochen werden, das Wichtigste in meinem Leben, da lass ich nichts drüber kommen. Also so ein türisches RTL-2-Ding. Das Kind spielt irgendwo in der Ecke, der Vater sieht nichts, es klettert halb aus dem Fensterfeld runter, nur die Nachbarn kriegen es hin, dass das Kind überhaupt überlebt an diesem Tag. Aber angesprochen auf das eigene Kind, raste der Vater quasi vor sich selber aus, spielt sich selber die Show vor, wie wichtig ihm das Kind ist. Und unter dieser Maßgabe, dass wir jetzt alle so ein RTL-2, Frauentausch, Assi bekommen...
Es ist auch gut, die Reportage kommt mir so vor, als sei das so ein RTL-2, so eine Reportage irgendwie. Es wäre auch schön, wenn sie jetzt so ein... Wie heißt diese Sendung? Frauentausch? Wenn jetzt vielleicht der Vater, der Mann von Baerbock auf Habeck aufpasst oder so.
Wir haben jetzt dieses selbstverwahrlosende Schauspiel eines Ich-nur-für-den-Dienst-Arbeit-ich-hier-nur-für-den-Dienst. Ich kann ja nichts delegieren, das kommt ja auf mich an. Ich muss ja hier 8 Uhr morgens usw. Und selbst dann esse ich halt ohne Milch mein Müsli. Aber dann mal explizit angesprochen auf Herr Habeck, was bedeutet für Sie Glück? Plötzlich die ganz andere Geschichte.
Was ist für Sie persönlich Glück?
Nicht zu rennen.
Also tatsächlich die kleinen stillen Freuden des Alltags, die eigentlich gar keine Freuden sind. Aber ganz am Anfang des Films habe ich mich darüber mokiert, dass die Milch alle ist und ich die Wäsche nicht gelegt habe. Weil die einfach keine Zeit, weil wir sind nachts um 3 oder um 4 nach Hause gekommen, morgens um 7 ging es weiter, über 14 Tage ungefähr. Und solche Dinge, die eigentlich alltägliche Last sind, sind im Moment ganz schön für mich. Also wenn ich mal den Rasen mähe, die Fenster putze, die Toilette sauber mache, das Einkaufen, all das, was eigentlich nervt, ist im Moment so ein kleines, stilles Glück des Alltags.
Das ist auch schön, ich könnte mir jetzt hier vorstellen, dass Habeck und Wälzer zusammen auf einem Buch schreiben, das kleine Glück.
Das kleine Glück des Alltags, das Klo putzen.
Ja, und wer kennt es nicht? Wer sagt nicht Hurra? Das würde ich jetzt gerne mal tun. Also es ist ja auch ziemlich traurig, wenn man sagt, klar, die meisten Menschen müssen diese reproduktive Arbeit machen. Aber dass man das jetzt als Glück ausmacht, da hätte man jetzt auch mal sagen können, ja, wenn ich einfach dann Zeit habe und kann mal Beethoven-Sonaten hören oder so. Das wäre ja eine akzeptable Antwort, aber zu sagen, ich putze mal die Fenster.
Also die ehrliche Antwort wäre gewesen...
Da könnte man doch lieber arbeiten gehen, würde ich sagen.
Die ehrliche Antwort wäre gewesen, Herr Feldenkirchen, Sie haben einen Film über mich gemacht. Und anstatt jetzt, dass ich bei meiner Frau bin, sitze ich mit Ihnen hier und gucke für andere, die zugucken, den Film, den Sie über mich gemacht haben. Also die Performance, und wir haben jetzt schon betont, wie wichtig Performance heute im politischen Diskurs ist usw. Die geht hier nicht auf, die passt auch nicht inhaltlich zusammen, die ist nicht kohärent, sie ist auch verlogen. Und das bekommt man spätestens dann wirklich serviert, wenn Robert Habeck explizit auf seine eigene eben im Film zur Schau gestellte Performance angesprochen wird und dann sagt, ne, das war eigentlich Blödsinn, was ich da performt habe. Ich habe ja gesagt, wie dumm kann man sein, jetzt zu regieren. So, und dann bricht es einfach auf. Also das ist einfach inkonsistenter Blödsinn, den wir hier sehen. Und wir haben uns schon darauf verständigt und sehen es auch ein, es geht nur um die Performance, aber die Performance ist halt wirklich bescheuert.
Mich lässt das an einen Schlager denken von Paola. Das ist die Übersetzung eines englischsprachigen Liedes. Und da geht es darum, dass zwei Mädchen in der Schule befreundet sind und dann trennen sich die Wege. Und die eine hat halt ein Alltagsleben, wo man auch Fenster putzen muss mit Kindern und so weiter. Und die andere wird halt Superstar und kennt die Pisten von St. Moritz und ist in der Welt unterwegs. Und dann wird das so geschildert in diesem Lied, also aus der Ich-Perspektive, der die Welt erobert hat. Und die singt dann im letzten Refrain. Ich träume oft davon, ein Zuhause zu haben, wo ich geborgen sein kann. Ich möchte so gern den Christbaum schmücken und auf den Urlaub sparen. Und du meinst aber, nee, willst du nicht, weil das kannst du ja machen. Du musst ja nicht in der ganzen Welt rum. Dann spar noch auf den Urlaub und schmück den Christbaum. Und das ist wirklich ganz erstaunlich, dass das hier in einem Format, das eigentlich zur Reflexion einladen soll, dafür sorgt, dass es noch viel täuschender wird.
Es ist nur Hypo-Performance statt Reflexion. Erinnert mich aber, was du eben gestellt hast, auch an LA Crash. Der Film hat ja mal einen besten Filmausgabe bekommen. Wo ja dann auch irgendwann nicht eine politische Figur, aber auch jemand, der sich quasi jeden Wunsch erfüllen kann, als Hausfrau einfach traurig zu Hause liegt. Und der Putzfrau sagen muss, sie sind meine beste Freundin. Sie sind die einzige Person, die ich vertraue. Und dazu darf es nicht kommen, auch in der Politik nicht. Wir hören noch zwei Clips von ihm, denn er wird jetzt hier gefragt, was ist denn jetzt Politik und so weiter? Was macht Politik aus?
Das Besondere am politischen Beruf ist, dass er immer öffentlich ist. Das ist die öffentliche Angelegenheit. Das heißt, das, was man sagt, wird immer bewertet. Und deswegen gibt es einen gewissen Zug im politischen System, sich nicht angreifbar zu machen.
Von ihm dann noch viel zu Amt und Person. Er hat festgestellt, als ich zuerst als Minister angesprochen wurde, habe ich gedacht, die kokettieren mit mir. Aber nein, die meinen ja wirklich Minister. Und es geht ja mit Verantwortung einher. Also hat er irgendwie die 100 Jahre alten Bücher von Weber gelesen. Hat es jetzt festgestellt, es betrifft ihn jetzt, dass er Minister ist. Und jetzt haben wir gehört, der politische Beruf ist immer öffentlich. Und da scheint bei ihm schon durch, ich bin ab jetzt immer öffentlich. Nur das stimmt ja gar nicht. Es ist eben nicht nur das Amt, sondern es ist ja die Trennung von Amt und Person. Man darf durchaus noch Person sein. Oder?
Also als Minister und als Vizekanzler, und das ist mir sehr bewusst, ist man in einer Repräsentationsrolle. Ich habe, als ich damals zum ersten Mal Minister wurde, am Anfang sehr damit gehadert, dass mich alle mit Herrn Minister angesprochen haben. Weil ich ja dachte, hey, ich bin doch der gleiche Typ wie gestern, der mit euch in der Schlange steht. Und ich bin doch Robert. Hab dann aber sehr schnell gemerkt, dass hinter der Anrede nicht eine Form von ironischer Unterwerfung steckt, sondern dass das Amt auch mit einem selber was macht. Als Amtsperson trifft man Entscheidungen, die man als private Person sich überhaupt nicht zumuten würde, geschweige denn treffen wollte. Und deswegen muss man im Ministeramt und im Vizekanzleramt anders agieren, anders sprechen. Man wird zu einem anderen Menschen. Man ist dann Repräsentant von Deutschland.
Jo, Digga.
Ist sicherlich kein ministerial angemessener Begriff.
Aber ernsthaft gefragt, wird es dem bisherigen Robert Habeck künftig noch geben?
Keine Ahnung. Ich versuche nicht so viel drüber nachzudenken, sondern mich über die Aufgabe zu definieren, wird die Aufgabe entscheiden, was aus mir wird.
Da könnte man vielleicht dann ein Buch mit Precht zusammen schreiben. Wer bin ich und wenn ja, wie viele? Klar ist man eine öffentliche Person dann, und es empfiehlt sich nicht als Vizekanzler, zum Beispiel besoffen durch die Straßen zu ziehen oder so.
Wäre nicht gut.
Aber wenn er einfach zu Hause ist bei seiner Familie, wenn er da irgendwo in seinem Kaff was essen geht, spazieren geht, dann würde ich vielleicht mal sagen, ach, das ist doch nicht hier, das ist doch der Kubicki, nee, das ist der Habeck, ach so. Und viel mehr passiert ja da nicht.
Ja, also, so wie Serdar Samonshu plötzlich überrascht ist von Annalena Baerbock, denke ich mir irgendwie, ey komm, du bist jetzt Vizekanzler, du hast es jetzt geschafft. Was laberst du uns noch voll damit? Ja, das ist doch irgendwie, das ist ja nicht mal Selbstempfindung, sondern das ist inszenierter Blödsinn mit Feldenkirchen. Und ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, wir kennen das ja aus der Bildzeitung, es muss dem Fisch schmecken und nicht dem Angler. Aber Feldenkirchen ist doch dreimal klüger als der Film, den er hier produziert hat. Und es muss ihnen doch auch selber auffallen. So viel Geld als Schmerzensgeld für so eine Art von Medienproduktion, kriegt er doch auch nicht dafür, dass das wirklich so gesendet wurde. Also ich finde das wirklich total Banane.
Ich müsste auch, ich müsste halt permanent lachen, wenn ich so ein Interview führen müsste.
Ja, das kann man eigentlich nicht ernst.
Stefan, bist du denn noch Stefan? Und wenn ich so mit dir reden würde. Ich kann dir sowieso, ist mir jetzt aufgefallen, Talkshows ja nur noch in so einem ganz komischen Modus mir vorstellen. Ich habe kürzlich mal die Chance gehabt, weil ich irgendwo zu Gast war. Da lief Plasberg und dann habe ich so 10 Minuten mitgeguckt. Dann stellte ich mir plötzlich vor, wie wäre das eigentlich, wenn diese Runde jetzt einfach so noch erweitert würde durch einen Platz und auf dem sitzt Bibo aus der Sesamstraße. Man muss sich das einfach mal dann so vorstellen, jede Talkshow, in der irgendwie noch so Bibo mitten drin sitzt. Und man hat dann auch wieder einen ironischen Zugang dazu. Ja, so wird es eigentlich nicht klappen, es wird auch gar nicht auffallen.
Ja, wir kommen immer wieder aufs Traumschiff zurück. Der Ausweg Ironie als Modus des Zuschauens ist eine Sackgasse. Und man kann aber hier das nicht nur ironisch...
Aber das hier ist ja ganz, ganz ins Ernst gemeint. Also wir können nur darüber lachen, aber dass man das selbst nicht versucht, ironisch abzufedern. Also das dann... Karl Lagerfeld wurde ja auch immer solche Fragen dann gefragt, wer sind sie denn in der Maske? Und dann hat er gesagt, weiß ich nicht, interessiert mich auch gar nicht, wer ich bin. Oder, doch, doch, ich stehe schon mit beiden Beinen auf dem Boden, nur nicht ist der Boden auf der Erde. Also so kann man ja auch damit umgehen, spielerisch mit Maskerade, mit Amte und Person und Würde und allem spielen. Aber das ist ja hier eine, weiß ich gar nicht, Selbsthilfegruppe, Beichtstuhl, alles zusammenkommt da.
Also gut, dass du nochmal Lagerfeld nennst. Lagerfeld war mal bei Lanz, sein letzter großer Auftritt in Deutschland, vielleicht schon ewig her. Und Markus Lanz musste das ganze Studio umbauen, weil Lagerfeld dann, ich setze mich doch nicht hin. Haben Sie eine Meise? Also Sie haben bitte hier einen Stehtisch und da einen und da einen und dann gehen wir ein bisschen hin. Und halten Sie ein iPad bereit, ich werde Sie zwischendurch in schwarz-weiß fotografieren. Legen Sie sich mal so auf die Treppe, ja? Und dann steht Lagerfeld so da und sagt zu Markus Lanz, und da sitzen noch Publikum und so weiter. Legen Sie sich mal hier so auf die Treppe und dann kann Markus Lanz gar nicht anders, weil er will ja auch das Fernseherlebnis gestalten, als sich dann so auf die Treppe zu legen. Und dann würde nur so ganz, ja, hier drei Fotos reichen.
Gucken Sie mal entspannt, das sieht aber nicht besonders entspannt aus. So hat er ja noch so anfangs verkrampft, ja.
Also Lagerfeld hat sie wunderbar vorgeführt, immer und bei Markus Lanz damals insbesondere. Das war wirklich toll. Und so was wie Habeck mit Fellenkirchen, das ist wirklich schlimm.
Gruseltheater, hoffentlich bleibt uns das jetzt erst mal erspart, dieses ganze Porträtfernsehen. Wir gehen jetzt, wo wir ja eh schon auf der Metaebene angekommen sind, gleich ins Metaverse. Und ich habe mich gefragt, wie werden wir jetzt reiche Metaverse? Was verspricht uns das Metaverse darum, soll es jetzt gehen? Es gibt eigentlich in eigenes YouTube-Genre schon Videos, die einem erklären, wie man reiche Metaverse wird. Wir werden da jetzt gleich Beispiele hören. Erst gehen wir ganz kurz in den US-Kongress. Da gab es eine Anhörung mit den Bitcoin-Minern und so weiter. Da war Brian Brooks von Bitfury zu Gast, also auch so eine Mining-Firma. Und der erklärt jetzt erstmal uns den Unterschied zwischen Web 1 und Web 2. Denn wir gehen ja mit Metaverse in Web 3. Auch wenn da immer wieder gesagt wird, man kann das nicht ganz identisch sehen, aber wir lassen das jetzt mal dabei.
So die Charakteristik des Web 1, wenn man sich das Original AOL Account erinnert, war die Möglichkeit, in einem kurierten Waldgarten ein Set von Content zu sehen, das nicht interaktiv war, sondern auf AOL vorgestellt wurde, wie die Time Magazine es zu den Artikeln, die sie in ihrem Magazin sehen wollten, auf einem Schrank zu sehen. Die Innovation des Web 2 war, dass man plötzlich nicht nur Content liest, sondern auch Content schreiben kann. Das war das, was die Blogosphere in den 90er Jahren und den frühen 2000ern angetan hat. Facebook, wie die Frau der Städte erwähnt hat, Google und zwei oder drei andere Unternehmen.
So, Web 1 war eigentlich so ein bisschen Schaufenster gucken. Was hat da jemand mit der Homepage gemacht? Dann kann ich mal sehen, ah ja, informiere ich mich. Web 2 heißt, ich schreibe mal selbst Blogs, Tweete, Poste, mache. Bin aber bei den Konzernen.
Das ganze Social Media so weiter.
Genau, bin bei den Konzernen. Brauchen wir nicht mehr alle nennen. Und jetzt aber, Web 5. Jetzt kommt die Befreiung.
What makes Web 3 different is the ability to own the actual network. And that's what crypto assets themselves represent, is an ownership stake in an underlying network. So when you hear people talk about, for example, Layer-1-Tokens, what they mean is, this is your reward for providing the ledger-maintenance-services, the computing power to the network, that on Web 1 and 2 was done by Google, right? So now people in my hometown of Pueblo, Colorado, can actually own the Ethereum network, but they can't own the Internet. That's owned by Google and a few other companies. That's what the project of crypto is all about, is allowing people to directly own the networks that have native assets that are supporting it. And that's the nature of decentralization, where the token holders are the people who control the asset.
Stefan, gehört uns jetzt bald das Internet wieder, wenn wir Web 3 haben?
Ja, ich hab's schon aufgerufen. Ich kann dafür Aufklärung sorgen. Das Wall Street Journal hat letztens getitelt, New research shows that just 0, 01% of Bitcoin holders controls 27% of the currency in circulation. Also von allen Bitcoins, die in Zirkulation sind, werden 27% ein Viertel von 0, 01% der Bitcoin-Holder gehalten. Es ist jetzt noch ein bisschen unklar, ob mit Bitcoin-Holder immer nur eine Wallet gemeint ist oder auch eine Person mit mehreren Wallets. Aber trotzdem ist es in einer Masse zentralisierte Anhäufung von Vermögen, und wir nehmen den Vermögensbegriff hier, weil die das ja mal als Geld sehen, dass wir nirgendwo anders sonst in dieser Art und Weise gesehen haben. Noch nie wurde Geld zentralisiert.
Dagegen ist Chile egalitär. Und jetzt bringt das auch auf den Punkt in Breitband Jürgen Goethe, der sagt, nee, Web3 ist auf keinen Fall hier die große Demokratisierungsmaschine.
Es geht diesen Personen sehr, sehr stark um die Idee von Besitz. Und daran ist halt auch diese Web3-Bewegung eine sehr konservative, wenn nicht sogar reaktionäre Bewegung. Denn wenn uns das Internet was gebracht hat, war es ja genau die Entkopplung, also hat es nicht immer umgesetzt, aber eines der Versprechen war die Entkopplung von Zugang und Besitz. Und das ist jetzt der Versuch, mit Web3 genau das wieder rückabzuwickeln, zu sagen, dass da jetzt alle dasselbe Bild, dieses lustige Bild, sich alle kopieren können, finden wir doof. Das muss eine Person besitzen, die muss das kontrollieren können, und die kann das dann ja vermieten oder verkaufen an andere, die das auch mal sehen wollen.
Darüber denkt man jetzt gerade bei YouTube nach, wie kann man da jetzt auch Besitzer werden? Ownership ist ja das große Wort. Finn Kliemann führt das ja auch laufend im Mund herum. Ich habe gesehen, hässlichste NFTs bietet jetzt auch Julian Bam an, der natürlich auch mit Krypto und so weiter jetzt noch mal richtig reibach macht. Naja, wir schauen jetzt in einen YouTube-Kanal rein, beziehungsweise hören rein von Graham Stephan. Er ist so ein Glücksritter, der schon Millionen wohl gemacht hat mit allen möglichen Kryptosachen und so. Und er begrüßt jetzt hier uns im Metaverse.
Ich nehme mal an, wenn er sagt Millionär, dann ist der Maßstab dafür noch US-Dollar. Wir müssen nämlich immer wieder uns vergegenwärtigen, dass in dieser ganzen post-apokalyptischen Szenerie die EZB de Fed enteignet uns, wir müssen uns dagegen wehren, versuchen dies mit einer Währung, also die nicht mal eine Währung ist, aber die sagen, es ist eine Währung, die nicht mal einen Stromausfall aushält oder keinen Handyempfang. Unglück damit.
Die natürlich nur als Komplementärwährung die ganze Zeit funktioniert.
Nur weil es den Dollar gibt.
Das heißt, die ist die ganze Zeit auf die Leitwährung, das ist nun mal der Dollar ausgerichtet. Und dann kann man sagen, der Euro spielt noch eine gewisse Rolle und so weiter. Aber es ist eine Währung, die nur sich an der Leitwährung orientieren kann. Anders ist ja gar kein Wert zu bemessen. Das ist das Amüsante. Jetzt werden wir aber erstmal eingeführt, was wir im Metaverse alles machen. Du hast uns ja schon gezeigt, wir können da ganz tolle Konferenzen bald abhalten. Es gab übrigens im Chat eben mal die Frage, ob wir wirklich nebeneinander sitzen. Das finde ich eine sehr schöne Frage. Ich weiß gar nicht, sollen wir sie aufklären? Sind wir schon im Metaverse? Aber ich kann mal hier reingreifen. Es sieht so aus, als würden wir uns nicht...
Ich kann hinter Wolfgang greifen und vor Wolfgang.
Aber ich kann dir jetzt auch einen Stift übergeben, dann wird es wirklich gruselig.
Wow, weil der hier so unscharf ist.
Wir sitzen wirklich zusammen und werden auch noch ein Schnitzel... Wir sitzen immer zusammen. Wir werden noch ein analoges Schnitzel essen gehen. Das letzte Mal war ich erkrankt, wenn wir nicht zusammensitzen. Wir sitzen hier ganz leibnachig nebeneinander. Wir könnten aber auch ins Metaverse gehen, zum Beispiel um ins Museum zu gehen.
Oder du baust einen Platz von Land in zentraler Land, den du dann zu jemanden rentieren kannst, der ein Casino bauen will, wo Menschen das Geld gambeln. Eigentlich kann alles, was in der physischen Welt gemacht werden, wieder in der Metaverse, außer dein Kostüm kann jeder sein, anywhere at any time.
Fragt sich nur, warum. Und ich würde auch hier gleich an sein Publikum adressieren. Liebe Leutchen, ihr geht doch eh nie ins Museum. Und jetzt wollt ihr plötzlich mal ins Metaverse Museum gehen. Da würdet ihr sonst nie 10 Euro ausgeben und euch mal Kunst ansehen.
Genau, das zum einen. Vor allem ins NFT Museum gehen, nehme ich mal an. Dann sieht man da den Beatle hängen. Von dem man weiß, er ist 69 Millionen Dollar wert, wenn man den Ethereum-Betrag umrechnet. Und nur deswegen geht man rein, weil er nämlich für Dollar bezahlt wurde. Und nicht, weil das Werk selbst irgendwas für sich aussagt. Klar, so ein Wimbebild und so. Das ist wirklich haarsträubend. Und mit der Sache, ja, da kann man dann dahin gehen. Also es gibt ja schon verschiedene Metaversen, Live-Konzerte und Kinos in Fortnite und so weiter. Und derzeit, oder jetzt, die Tage lief ja zum Beispiel kein Chaos Communication-Kongress in Leipzig. Es gibt aber die RC3 World, wo man so in 2D-Bits-Grafik irgendwie und so weiter, das ist noch super attraktiverer als so ein Museum, weil da sind nämlich auch andere Nicht-Kongress-Besucher, die sich trotzdem die Zeit nehmen und weder dieses Jahr noch letztes Jahr habe ich nur eine Sekunde Gedanken daran verschwendet, da teilzunehmen, weil das für mich nicht es ist einfach. Also es ist einfach, ich will nicht vor einem Bildschirm sitzen, Dopamin getrieben, aber eben weit weg zum Oxytocin, warum das so eine große Rolle spielt, den Rentnerpublik lesen. Aber das ist einfach, das ist nicht die Zukunft, das ist nicht die Zukunft.
Vielleicht aber das hier als Geschäftsmodell.
Wir haben da jetzt ein Spiel, Sandbox, das ist eine Virtual Game, die.
Die Sandbox, da kann man Sand kaufen, verkaufen und so weiter und man kann auch Ownership betreiben in Land, also man kann Landlord werden und das war ja einfach viel attraktiver als in der realen Welt, wo ich denke ja klar, da ist ja auch schon viel weggekauft und jetzt haben wir also hier ein programmiertes Spiel, in dem man einfach gesagt hat, es gibt so und so viel Parzellen, die können gekauft werden und damit hat man eine Knappheit, aber eine künstliche Knappheit natürlich geschaffen und jetzt soll also ein Anreiz entstehen, dass Leute sagen, ja ich kauf auch das Land und plötzlich wollen mehr Leute Land haben, als es Land gibt, damit steigt die Nachfrage, das Angebot bleibt aber knapp und dann generiert man Geld damit, ich muss hier nochmal deutlich betonen, keinen Wert, also man sieht ja einfach, was das für ein Unsinn ist, der hier stattfindet, also zu sagen, ich kauf jetzt wirkliches Land, hat ja, auch wenn das alles problematisch ist, nur noch einen Sinn, weil es ja tatsächlich knapp ist, aber hier hat einfach ja mal jemand gesagt, wir machen es knapp, also das ist so, wenn wir sagen würden, ja heute darf den Podcast, Wir hören den Podcast, aber dürfen den nur 200 Leute hören.
Ja, ich erlaube mir jetzt mal ein ganz vulgär intellektuelles Argument und sage in der Art und Weise, wie die Wunschlisten über eine erträumte Lebenswelt schreiben, habe ich das bisher nur barmermals gesehen.
Wohnen ist ja ein großes Thema hier.
Stimmt.
Auch im Metaverse.
Besonders, wenn du dich in die Metaverse direkt investieren willst, kannst du das durch Land, Produkte oder die unterliegende Krypto-Kurrenz machen. Aber wir beginnen mit der Land. Das zentrale Land ist nur 90.000 Plätze und das ist es. Jetzt sind die Preise von rund 15.000 Dollar im Low End bis zu Millionen Dollar im Bezug auf die aktuellen Befragungspreise. Das gleiche gilt für Sandbox, wo manche 10.000 bis 150.000 Dollar für verschiedene Orte betreiben, mit einigen betreiben Millionen Dollar, wie ich vorhin erwähnt habe.
Ich habe letztens gestern genau genommen eine Reportage über die Billionärse Row in New York City gesehen. Ist dir das schon begriffen? Das ist relativ neu. In New York gibt es jetzt neue Hochhausansiedlungen, die reine Wohnhäuser sind, super schmal gebaut, also wirklich im Verhältnis zu 1 zu 17 mal, was Länge, Breite und Höhe angeht und so. Und da sind diese Wohntürme, die 400, 500 Meter, alles was bisher in New York gebaut wurde überstrahlen, absolut hässliche, weil einfach nur aufgestapelte Wohnungen sozusagen und die werden für hunderte Millionen pro Stück verkauft und in so ein Wohnhaus passen dann irgendwie 40 Wohnungen statt wie in den Trump Tower 300 oder so. Also du bist da ganz weit weg von irgendeiner sozialen Sinnhaftigkeit, dass das irgendwas mit Wohnen zu tun hat oder so. Es sind reine Investitionsmöglichkeiten, weshalb die Häuser auch zur Hälfte leer stehen und die andere Hälfte wird so alle drei Monate mal besucht von den eigenen. So und das ist eine Investition, bei der sich die Menschen für Immobilien entscheiden, aber jedes Risiko ausschließen wollen. Was zum Beispiel besteht, wenn du dir auf Mallorca einfach ein Grundstück, weil du dann nicht weißt, welcher Gauner kommt da vorbei und bricht da ein und zerstört dir irgendwas und so weiter. Weil die gucken einfach in Google Maps, ob das Haus noch steht und dann wissen sie, da gibt es nur einen Fahrstuhl hin in meine 60. Etage. Der Nachbar von oben macht keinen Ärger und der von unten auch nicht. Und ansonsten besteht da keine Gefahr von irgendwas. Solange das Haus steht, hat das seinen Wert. So und wenn ich sowas und da habe ich schon gedacht, wie dumm und sowas ist noch dümmer, wenn ich das hier unter dem Label Real Estate höre.
Nun fragt man sich, wie kann es überhaupt sein, dass es einen Anreiz gibt, möglicherweise zu sagen, ach, der hat ja dieser Landlord da so einen tollen Platz und hat da dies und das gebaut. Ich zahle dem Miete. Wie kann es überhaupt dazu kommen, dass diese Begehrlichkeit besteht, so sehr dahin zu wollen, dass man jetzt bereit wäre, einem solchen digitalen Landlord im Metaverse, bei The Sandbox oder sonst wo, Geld zu zahlen? Matthew Ball hat ja einige Essays geschrieben über das Metaverse. Im Salon werde ich nicht ein Essay von Matthew Ball vorstellen, mal von jemand anderes zum Metaverse. Also du merkst das Thema, das mich schon sehr fasziniert gerade. Und Matthew Ball sagt, wir müssen uns Fortnite nicht als ein Spiel vorstellen, sondern das ist einfach der Ort der Begegnung für viele junge Leute, vor allem aber das Publikum wird ja älter. Und nun kann es sein, dass man einfach sagt, gewisse Gruppen, gewisse junge Leute, gewisse wer auch immer sagen, wir treffen uns heute da und dort. Aber das kostet dann zum Beispiel Geld, dort sich aufweiten zu können. Es ist in etwa so, wie wenn du jetzt gleich sagst, ich gehe jetzt ein Schnitzel essen, das bedeutet für mich ja, ich muss, wenn ich mit dir weiter sozialen Kontakt haben will, mit in das Restaurant muss also auch Geld ausgeben. Und genauso kann das auch dann in der digitalen Welt sein, dass dann, es heißt, wir treffen uns dort oder wir hören uns dort gemeinsam das Konzert an, aber jeder muss halt dann die 10 Dollar oder 10 Tokens kaufen.
Das ist dieser soziale Login-Effekt, den wir von Facebook und so weiter kennen.
Und dieser soziale Login-Effekt, der jetzt noch gratis war bei Facebook, da haben wir nur mit den Daten bezahlt, der soll jetzt auch so ausgestaltet werden, dass man wirklich auch dort nochmal bezahlen kann. Dieser Graham Stephan ist ein bisschen cleverer, scheint mir dann immerhin, dass er sagt, ich mach jetzt mal bei Sandbox Sand kaufen oder Land kaufen, hm, weiß nicht. Er macht jetzt erstmal Folgen, weil er ja da im Metaverse reich werden will.
So in Terms von meinem eigenen Investiment, und wie ich mit dem Plan, eine Million Dollar zu investieren, throughout the Metaverse in 2022, hier ist das, was ich mache. Ich glaube, dass es jetzt zu spekulativ ist, die Land oder die Krypto-Kurrenz direkt zu kaufen. Deswegen würde ich es eher sicher spielen und in die Firmen zu investieren, die ich glaube, langefristig gut machen. Das betrifft Investitionen in Google, Apple, Facebook, Matterport, Snapchat, NVIDIA und AMD.
So viel zur Dezentralisierung, also er unterstützt einfach die Unternehmen, die ohnehin schon die Big Player sind, weil die sich auch im Metaverse ausbreiten werden. Und das ist im Prinzip auch genau das, was Matthew Ball, der sehr affirmativ auch darüber schreibt und der ja auch mit Suckerberg schon Talks hatte, was er aber auch am Ende seines Essays schreibt, dass sich ja etwas erheblich verändert mit dem Metaverse, dass wir am Anfang ein Internet hatten, das sehr verknüpft war mit Staaten, mit Militär, mit NGO und so und dann hat sich das alles so ausgebreitet und dann gab es diese Kapitalkonzentration, was zu den Konzernen geführt hat. Jetzt mit Metaverse haben wir eine Ebene, wo schon diese mächtigen Akteure direkt auftreten und jetzt eine Landverdrängung machen können, wo also die Kleinen gar nicht mehr die Chance haben, der einfache Blogger oder so sich zu tummeln. Das ist ein ganz, ganz großes Problem jetzt für Metaverse.
Also du hast die Möglichkeiten dort tätig zu sein, aber nur im Rahmen des Metaverse, wie es dir gestaltet wird von den Großen. Also es ist ein bisschen wie die Suche der Europäischen Union, also genau genommen der Europäischen Kommission, nach dem neuen Wirtschaftswachstumsmodell im Rahmen der Landschaft, die man schon hat. Also Nationalstaaten, Unternehmen, alles schon angesiedelt. Jetzt fehlt nur noch die Idee. Und so ein bisschen hat man ja den Eindruck, Facebook, drei Milliarden monatlich aktive Nutzer. Was kommt als nächstes? Na ja, die eine Milliarde, die aus Afrika noch nicht zugeschaltet sind, helfen jetzt dem Stock nicht weiter. Was besiedelt man nun? Und dann kommt es halt darauf an, ob man dieses Exklusivitätsding im, ich sag mal, analogen 2D, Facebook wirklich in die 3D-Welt rüberbekommt und darüber dann den sozialen Log-in-Effekt ausgestaltet, dass man halt wirklich sagt, also hier findet ein Coldplay-Konzert statt, aber es kostet halt ein Tritt.
Wir haben jetzt gehört, man kann hier also Rentier-Kapitalist werden. Das heißt, man vermietet nur noch Wohnung, Land oder verkauft Sand weiter, was auch immer. Aber wie ist es eigentlich mit Arbeit im Metaverse? Darüber berichtet der YouTuber Jordan Welch, auch er so ein Glücksritter. Wir hören uns mal die Einführung an. Ein Selbstversuch, wie kann ich jetzt möglichst schnell Geld verdienen im Metaverse? Also hier geht es nicht um langfristige Investitionen, sondern ich will jetzt einfach mal einen Job da haben.
Ich weiß, was ihr denkt, Gaming?
Aber hör mich auf für einen Sekunden. Diese Spiele sind von der Blockchain ausgerichtet, die gleiche Technologie, die alle Krypto-Bildungen aufbaut.
Und grundsätzlich, wenn man diese Spiele spielt, wird man in Krypto gewonnen.
Zum Beispiel in Axie Infinity, die die größte Spielzeit von ihnen alle zu verdienen ist.
In Plätzen wie die Philippinen oder Venezuela ist das eine sehr gute, halbe Zeitwerte.
Das muss man ein bisschen erklären, weil man sagt, ja, wie kann man in einem Spiel Geld verdienen? Also es geht jetzt nicht darum, dass es ein Glücksspiel ist, wo man Geld verdienen kann, wie so in einem Spielautomaten, sondern du spielst in diesem Spiel und wirst dann dafür belohnt für Ausdauer und Erfolg. Und du kannst damit etwas erwerben. Und die Sache ist jetzt die, also es gibt verschiedene Modelle, dass zum Beispiel ja Leute sagen, ich will für meine Figur einen anderen Skin haben. Also dass man sagt, ich hätte gerne meine Figur eigentlich in grün oder die sollen Hütchen tragen oder die soll die und die Waffe haben.
Genau, im Grunde ist das alles digitaler Waffenhandel.
Genau, das ist auch digitaler Waffenhandel, ganz richtig. Und jetzt kann ich sagen, ich erarbeite mir das, indem ich sage, ich habe 45 Level gespielt und dann habe ich diese Utensilien bekommen, die ich brauche. Oder ich kann sagen, ich kaufe mir die. Ich kaufe mir die einfach dazu, denn oft ist es ja bei Spielen jetzt so, dass die kostenlos sind oder fast kostenlos sind und dass die das eigentliche Geld so verdienen. Und jetzt kann man sich das also erarbeiten und kann das Erarbeitete, also das Produzierte, wenn man so möchte, so wie ich habe getöpfert, du willst einen Topf kaufen, so kannst du das jetzt auch da Metaverse machen. Was aber immer natürlich bedeutet, das muss man nochmal ganz klar sich klar machen, das funktioniert diese Wirtschaft nur, wenn es die andere Wirtschaft, nämlich unsere Volkswirtschaft, gibt. Weil der muss ja halt am Ende doch eine Pizza essen und muss sich die Zähne putzen können und so weiter. Das heißt, das andere muss alles schon produziert worden sein, um sich dann diese Meta-Welt zu begeben.
Du bist vor allem nicht der einzige Marktteilnehmer, sondern du sitzt an deinem Schreibtisch mit deiner Pizza und gleichzeitig sitzen aber zehn kleine Jungs in Bangladesch im Keller und können das Spiel viel besser als du.
Du hast es erkannt und auch darum wird es jetzt noch gehen. Ich kenne das Spiel nicht, er guckt dann erst mal XG Infinity, da will er mitspielen, das ist aber so langweilig, dass man es gar nicht aushält. Das ist ja wie Gras beim Wachsen zusehen. Und dann spielt er jetzt Seton Arena und dann fällt ihm auf, naja eigentlich so richtig gut spielen kann man erst dann, wenn man sich eine Figur kauft. Und dann kann man auch wieder mehr erwirtschaften, das heißt aber man hat dem Konzern auch schon Geld gegeben. Das heißt, das ist im Prinzip auch so ein bisschen wie so ein Franchise-Modell, also du kannst nicht einfach ein Starbucks aufmachen, sondern musst dann jeden Monat was abdrücken, dass du das überhaupt spielen kannst.
Aber du brauchst halt nur einen Verkäufer, von dem du es kriegst und findest aber selber zwei Käufer.
Ganz genau, also das ist hier alles Pyramidensystem, Ponzi-Skimen und so, all diese Dinge kommen hier vor. Jetzt zum Stundenlohn. Einige Tage vor, war ein Token fast ein Dollar wert. Das ist quasi zweimal die Minimumwage-Salare in Amerika.
Aber wenn wir etwas mehr in die Wirtschaft sinken, dann ist es ein kleines Verlust in der Wirtschaft.
Ja, das funktioniert alles natürlich immer nur, wenn man dann gewinnt und diese Kryptowährungen, auf denen das beruht, sind volatil. Das heißt, man kann dann auch sehr wenig verdienen. Was immer von beiden im Übrigen als Argument gebracht wird in dem Video ist, ja, jetzt ist das vielleicht für uns nicht so viel Geld, aber du hast ja gesagt, Bangladesch oder andere Länder, für die ist das ganz toll. Die können 900 Dollar im Monat verdienen dort. Und das ist doch unglaublich, wenn man das mal vergleicht mit dem Durchschnittslohn dann in diesen armen Ländern.
Es ist ziemlich viel Banane an dem Zeug, weil du musst auch jeden Tag wieder neu dir erstmal den, was wird überhaupt gehandelt?
Ja, und das hier bei Vita Arena ist es so, dass du kannst eine Spielfigur, mit der du dann erfolgreich bist, nur eine gewisse Anzahl von Tagen überhaupt spielen. Und dann fällt die weg und dann fängst du wieder bei Null an. Das heißt, du kannst nicht sagen, das habe ich mir jetzt erwartet, es geht weiter. Also man ist total der Willkür dieser Spielekonzerne ausgesetzt, beziehungsweise der anderen Digitalkonzerne, wie die jetzt sich gerade mal vorgestellt haben, du Geld verdienen kannst oder sollst oder nicht. Und es gibt noch eine andere Möglichkeit, dass es jetzt, also ich spiele etwas, ich kann aber doch auch jetzt einfach sagen, ich schlüpfe wie in der Konferenz jetzt so ein Metaverse, hinein und mache da zum Beispiel den Konferencier oder so. Der meistpopuläre Job hier ist eigentlich ein Casino-Host.
Ja, endlich Westworld. Ja, ich guck's ja grad wieder so ein bisschen. Äh, ist cool. Ich hab mich schon bei den Clips vorher mal gefragt. Du sitzt ja auch da und spielst oder arbeitest jetzt hier in so einem Ding. Und die Konkurrenz kann ja immer auch ein anderer Computer sein. Also, irgendwer, der dann denkt, oh, ich kann ja auch eine KI einfach machen, ich brauch ja gar nicht zehn Bangladeschis oder so. Sondern, und dann, was machst denn dann eigentlich? Dann ist ja dein Job von heute auf morgen, K.o. geschlagen, musst ein neues Spiel suchen, wo noch niemand auf die Idee kam, das per Computer danach zu armen, was da zu spielen ist.
Die Frage ist auch, mit wem er sich hier unterhält. Also, jedenfalls treffen sich jetzt hier zwei im Metaverse. Er, Welch, ist jetzt dort, hat den Job angetreten, macht das aber dann am Ende doch nicht, spielt dann nachher doch lieber im Casino ein bisschen rum. Aber er trifft jetzt da den Konferencier oder Host des Casinos.
So I'm a Metaverse employee and it's my job just to kind of come in, just to make sure things are flowing, you know, players are happy, tables are working, you know, sometimes perhaps some issues, but most of the time it works really well, it's real fun.
How much money could you make at the top of having a job in this world? Ja, aber wir haben jetzt hier also auch von dieser Unabhängigkeit und Selbstständigkeit bewegen wir uns einfach jetzt einen 9-to-5-Job hinein und dass das auf Dauer so natürlich nicht funktionieren kann, ist absolut klar und auch keine Volkswirtschaft kann so funktionieren, aber es ist etwas, was wahnsinnig gut angesehen ist. Natürlich auch deshalb, weil die Aufstiegsträume so sehr zerplatzt sind schon und die Hoffnung ist natürlich, dass man dort was anderes erleben kann. Wir hören jetzt in den kanadischen Podcast Tech Won't Save Us hinein, da ist Steven Deal zu Gast und der sagte einiges mal zum Thema Dezentralisierung und Skalierung.
Die einzige Art, wie diese Dinge skalaieren, ist letztendlich, dass sie die sehr zentralisierten Systeme werden, die sie verwendet haben, um zu verändern. Und die Problematik mit diesen Technologien ist, dass sie sich an dieser Dezentralisierung.
Die bauen eigentlich die Welt nach und sehen, ach guck mal, da haben die aber richtig gut immer verdient, so Kreditkarten, Dienstleister und sowas. Also wenn wir das mal schaffen, im Metaverse auch den Leuten anzudienen und wenn wir da als Platzhirsche recht früh vor Ort sind, dann können wir ja richtig gut mal da verdienen.
Letztens habe ich bei Fefel dieses Argument gelesen, SAP geht in die Unternehmen und optimiert immer den Marktführer und vertreibt das dann als Software für die Nicht-Marktführer mit dem Hinweis, also wenn ihr es so macht, wenn ihr euer Unternehmen um diese Softwareung rumgestaltet, dann macht ihr es wie der Marktführer, funktioniert fast nie, aber ist immer wieder gut und das Metaverse ist genau diese Verdrehung, wir haben ja keine Idee oder so, sondern wir organisieren rund um die Technik das, was wir eigentlich auch so haben, fragt sich dann, brauche ich jetzt eine digitale Pizza oder nicht einen digitalen Pizza Lieferanten, aber es kommt immer so, immer diese Silicon Valley Idee wieder vor, da sehen junge Männer, die irgendwann aus dem Schoß ihrer Mutter entlassen wurden und dann bauen sie sich das nach, dieses Servicefeld und so weiter. Also diese Nachahmung, die da stattfindet, ist immer wieder sehr bezeichnend. Da wird man auch, da muss man glaube ich nur ein paar Jahrzehnte ins Land laufen und jetzt schaut man sich das an und so, das war damals die Idee von Gesellschaft und so.
Und noch mal zur Illusionen-Dezentralisierung.
And generally for what I've seen, with the centralized network so far and we see this manifest everywhere in crypto, is that who is actually getting rich off of these things? And this is the exact opposite of democratization. This is plutocracy.
Ja, sehr schön gesagt. Und wir hören noch einen letzten Clip, denn Glücksspiel hat jetzt ja hier schon einen gewissen Stellenwert gehabt im Metaverse und das wird auch nochmal von Deal auf den Punkt gebracht.
Ja, das ist die Dopamin-Galaxie.
Und im Prinzip müsste man ja da… Abonniertes Unglück. Da müsste man jetzt doch eigentlich schon vorab sagen, wir müssen ganz schnell regulieren. Und das ist etwas, was Yevgeny Morozov in der FAZ gefordert hat. Er hat einen Artikel geschrieben, der damit schon einsteigt. Olaf Scholz ist jetzt der neue Kanzler. Also er sagt gleich, Achtung, eigentlich richtig, mich jetzt, und das macht man ja, wenn man eine FAZ schreibt, an die Regierung. Für die Morgenlage, Doppelpunkt. An die fünf Leser noch, sondern man richtet sich in erster Linie an die Regierung, weil man weiß, die nehmen das natürlich zur Kenntnis. Und da sagt er, ist der sogenannte Tech-Clash die Kluft zwischen den Tech-Business-Modellen und der Gesellschaft also überbrückt? Keineswegs. Denn etwas Seltsames ist passiert. Ein Teil der Tech-Industrie scheint nun ganz wild darauf zu sein, den anderen Teil zu zerschlagen. Wir kennen das ja jetzt, jetzt haben ja viele Facebook als Feind und und und. Und er sagt dann, angestachelt von chronisch hungrigen Risikokapitalgebern, attackiert die neue Generation von Start-ups das stark zentralisierte, werbebasierte Modell von Google und Facebook als unfair gegenüber den Nutzern. Die utopische Welt des Web 2.0 mit ihren Versprechungen von kostenlosen oder zumindest subventionierten Diensten erscheint plötzlich dystopisch. Auch Teile der alten Garde haben das Licht gesehen. Jack Dorsey, Mitbegründer und langjähriger Geschäftsführer von Twitter, hat seinen Job aufgegeben, um mehr Zeit damit zu verbringen, über Bitcoin und El Salvador zu twittern. Und er sagt dann, eine Lektion kann man aus dem früheren Web 2.0 Debakel lernen. Es gibt auf diesem Gebiet keine Regulierung, die verfrüht oder zu wenig aggressiv wäre. Will Olaf Scholz verhindern, dass die Ambitionen seiner Regierung in den Bereichen Klima, Finanzen und Technologie in die Lehre von Krypto versinken, sollte er sich dieser existenziellen Herausforderung stellen?
Also um eine kleine Anekdote, wie ich sie auch so in den Rentnerpublik schreibe. Francis Horgan hat uns aufgeklärt darüber, wir haben es ja hier auch besprochen, die Facebook-Files und so weiter, wie krass Instagram die Jugendlichen, vor allem jungen Mädels, in die Essgestörtheit, in die psychischen Krankheiten stürzt. So und das fanden alle so gravierend, dass sie vom US-Kongress aus gesagt hat, dass sie im britischen Parlament eingeladen wurde, um offiziell auszusagen, dass sie im europäischen Parlament eingeladen wurde, um offiziell vor dem entsprechenden Ausschuss auszusagen. Aber was eigentlich mit Deutschland? Während wir mit Christine Lambrecht in Personalunion die Familien- und Justizministerin hatten, hat Francis Horgan hier nur einen Fototermin bekommen. Und das sagt alles. Das ist auch die neue Regierung. Also mal gucken. Eine spiegele ich halt sehr viel von dem, was ich bis jetzt gehört habe von ihr. Aber hier muss man jetzt so tiefgreifend einschauen, weil und das ist eigentlich das Argument, also das Ökonomische ist auch super wichtig. Aber diese Maschinen, diese Computer sind Unglücksmaschinen. Die machen die User wirklich unglücklich. Es gibt diese eine, deren Name ich das kann, es steht dann alles in Rennauberblick, aber es gibt in Amerika eine Reihenuntersuchung, die in Deutschland vergleichbar ist mit dem sozioökonomischen Peniel vom DIW und so, wo die wirklich mit Milliardenbudget seit 40 Jahren sich einfach die Jugendlichen anschauen und die haben eine Standardfrage, die sie seit 1990 an die 12-Klässler stellen, also ein Panel. Bist du gerade glücklich? Und das vergleichen die dann mit Bildschirmnutzung. Und es ist eine eindeutige Korrelation übers Fernsehen und jetzt übers Internet hinweg. Umso mehr Bildschirme, umso weniger Zufriedenheitsempfinden, dass man so darstellt. Egal welche Inhalte, egal was. Und wie schon angemerkt hier, es ist das Dopamin. Das hat man im Fernsehen schon immer. Aber im, also dieses Ganze, wir organisieren das Web 2 so wie ein Spielautomat, die ganze Facebook-App und so weiter. Das ist einfach dieses Dopamin-gesteuertes Zeug. Und da kommt das Oxytocin komplett unter die Räder. Also das sogenannte Kuschelhormon. Dass man manchmal bei Jugendlichen feststellt, dass eine körperliche Berührung von einem Schwarm oder so, ja man ist so 15, der Junge, das Mädel, das hat man schon immer gemacht. Und dann kommt es zu einer zufälligen Berührung. Und die führt zu einem Oxytocinausstoß in dem Moment, der im Gehirn ankommt, wie ein Drogenrausch. So und das kriegst du aber bildschirmvermittelt niemals hin. Dafür brauchst du einfach räumliche Nähe, die Erwartung und die Chance auf körperlichen Kontakt und dann vielleicht den körperlichen Kontakt. So und das ist einfach hier nicht gegeben. Also das ist einfach wirklich verlorenes Land. Hier stürzt man die Leute in Unglück, wie wir es ansonsten nur in Hollywood so gesehen haben. Was weiß ich, Wally und so.
Hollywood ist schon das richtige Stichwort. Ich habe noch einen Clip. Hans Zimmer war bei Carole Fischer. Hast du wahrscheinlich gehört?
Ich habe gehört, dass es das Gespräch gibt.
Ich dachte, du könntest es mir jetzt schon auswendig aufsagen.
Sway höre ich immer nur punktuell.
Im Gegensatz zu mir, ein Hans Zimmer Fan bist. Aber wir sind jetzt hier im Metaverse-Zeitalter dort angekommen, dass ich Hans Zimmer zustimme, wenn auch nicht musikalisch so, aber inhaltlich, was er hier zu sagen hat. Facebook, das sich hier zu Meta verändert hat, hat sich entschieden, dass sie den Metaverse zu haben. Aber es ist das Metaverse. Mein Geräusch ist Waa Waa.
Hans Zimmer ist ja in diesem Business. Das wird ja immer unterschätzt. Es gibt einen sehr schönen. Ich habe es nie wieder gefunden. Vielleicht habe ich es mir auch noch ausgedacht. Aber Hans Zimmer war damals auch in Frage, Tom Tück was Parfüm zu vertonen, bevor Tom Tück das mit den Berlinern selber gemacht hat. Und da war die Frage, das Parfüm riecht ja nach etwas. Und der Film kann das aber nicht darstellen. Und Hans Zimmer wusste, wenn ich die Herausforderung annehme, ist es für mich der Auftrag, den Geruch im Film erlebbar zu machen, über die Musik. Und dann würde ich sagen, das geht. Und jetzt ist Hans Zimmer genau in diesem Business, wo es darum geht, Emotionen zu gestalten, Räume zu vervollständigen, wie auch immer. So ein Erlebnis zu untermalen, weil es das visuelle Erlebnis alleine nicht schafft. Und er kann das. Und das war genau seine richtige Antwort auf diejenigen, die das im Silicon Valley technikgetrieben versuchen, auch zu machen. Dreimal laut schnarchen und sagen, ey Leute, das ist alle irre.
Wir können da nur zustimmen und stimmen wahrscheinlich dann auch Jens Lenye zu, der auch dort zu Gast war und auch zu Metaverse befragt wurde. Und es ist ganz ähnlich, wie Hans Zimmer sieht.
So eine der Dinge, die du gesagt hast, ist, dass Metaphor die Menschheit zerstört.
Reden wir mal um die dunkle Seite.
Was müssen wir über das denken?
Die ökonomischen Zentren in der Wirtschaft sind, um mehr und mehr Behinderungsveränderungen über Menschen zu beherrschen.
Und dann sterben wir, denn Menschen haben leichte Bodies und unsere Intelligenz ist das einzige, das uns weitergeht, sonst essen wir, also essen wir, und dann sind wir weg.
Genau so. Und in Don't Look Up wird es ja auch wunderbar dargestellt, wie dieser Silicon Valley Superfuzzi da dem Wissenschaftler aus seinen Daten über sein Verhalten rausgelesenes Schicksal vorträgt und wir am Ende des Films sehen, ne, der Widerspruch liegt in der Handlung selbst. Es ist einfach, ja, grandios. Na ja, was haben wir hier noch zum Abschluss an Clips? Einen will ich auf jeden Fall noch spielen, denn wir haben hier ganz ausführlich, ich weiß noch, Januar 2020 die Europäische Kommission, Ursula von der Leyen, alle suchen ein neues Wirtschaftsmodell, Green Deal, Green Finance, Pipapo und jetzt ist ja, läuft ja hier in Europa gerade eine mega Auseinandersetzung. Darum sind französische Atomkraftwerke eigentlich klimafreundlich. Also können wir die mit unter, ja, da kann man Green Finance-mäßig reingehen oder, und das war dann so eine deutsche Idee, ja, so Wasserstoff oder Erdgas, auch graues Erdgas, es gibt ja grünes und graues Gas, also Gas, das man über Strom und dann Wasserspaltungen erzeugt, das können wir in grün, und da man das substituieren kann, also man hat erstmal eine Gasleitung und dann schickt man erstmal Erdgas rein oder dann schickt man so 10% grünes Gas und 20 und irgendwann halt 100, deswegen könnten wir ja Erdgas als Brückentechnologie mitnehmen, müssten das dann also auch Green Labeln, da haben sich natürlich auch viele aufgeregt, weil diese Idee von Olaf Scholz ist ja völlig Banane, so was zu machen. Wenn es eine Brückentechnologie ist, muss man das auch so Labeln, was kann man denn... Ich kann es nicht taxonomisch einfach sagen. Das ist halt grün. Und zu dieser ganzen Diskussion, von der wir auch schon hier gesagt haben, mehrfach. Wir haben die Texte von dem BlackRock-Chef gelesen, Larry Fink und so weiter. Am Ende ist die politische Entscheidung gar nicht so entscheidend, sondern die Frage ist, wie wird das Investitionsgeld gelenkt? Nach welchen Regeln? Und das wird eben jetzt gerade ausklamüsert. Taxonomie nennt sich das Vorhaben der Europäischen Kommission, nämlich zu sagen, das wird jetzt gelabelt als green und das als nicht green. Und dann werden die Investitionsströme so langsam, BlackRock hat es vorgemacht, auch staatlich gesteuert, hinsichtlich Nachhaltigkeit gelenkt. Und zu dieser Taxonomie, und wir hören noch ein bisschen den Bericht vorher, hat Olaf Scholz folgenden Spruch dargelassen.
Polen und Ungarn wollen, dass Erdgas und Atomenergie auf dieser Liste stehen. Das wollen andere Länder auch. Aber der Kommission ein Ultimatum stellen, das wollten sie nicht. Und weil der EU-Gipfel grundsätzlich nur einstimmige Beschlüsse fasst, scheiterte die Kompromisssuche kurz vor Mitternacht. Kurz nach Mitternacht demonstrierten dann Olaf Scholz und Emmanuel Macron in ihrer gemeinsam abgehaltenen Pressekonferenz, wie sie mit diesem Scheitern nun umgehen wollen. Zuerst redete der eine das Problem klein.
Die Frage wird völlig überbewertet.
Die Taxonomie ist ein kleines Thema in einer ganz großen Frage. Nämlich in der Frage, wie Europa klimaneutral werden kann.
Nein, die Taxonomie ist nicht ein kleines Thema in einer großen Frage, sondern es ist der Kern der Weltrettung.
Ja, also das ist ja auch an jedem Wirtschaftsplatz zu lesen. Beziehungsweise die sagen nicht, damit retten wir die Welt, sondern die haben natürlich auch große Sorge, was wird da sein damit. Aber meine Güte, wo wird das dann hinführen? Ja, das ist... Jetzt steigen wir so aus dem alten Jahr raus.
Ja, wir könnten uns natürlich...
Hast du noch was Lustiges, frage ich jetzt mal?
Also Facebook wird in Kalifornien von den Rohingya in Myanmar verklagt, weil es da 2017 zum Genozid wegen Volksverletzung und so weiter gekommen ist, wegen Fake News auf und so weiter. Nee, das ist...
Das ist dann vielleicht auch nicht das Lustige.
Also ich hätte hier noch im Angebot Florian Schröder darüber, redet darüber, wie Angst in der politischen Kommunikation missbraucht wird, um Dumme, eigentlich der Impfung, ist mir egal, aber jetzt bin ich plötzlich Impfgegner, weil missbraucht wird, aber das ist auch nicht sehr aufmunternd. Die Kindergrundsicherung könnte den Anspruch verwirklichen, Kinder aus der Armut zu beseitigen, sagt Ulrich Schneiders, müssen wir auch nicht als Clip hören. Wir hören uns mal einen an. Eine Minute 43, nee, das ist zu lang. Ich referiere kurz. Der Europäische Gerichtshof hat jetzt in einem Streit, und ich habe mir keine Notiz gemacht, in welchem Land irgendwo da im Osten gesagt, wenn ihr als Richter national Sorgen habt, dass euer Verfassungsgericht vielleicht die Korruption im Lande vorantreibt, dann ignoriert es einfach und haltet euch an uns. Und das ist natürlich jetzt eine große Herausforderung für das Bundesverfassungsgericht, das er eigentlich schon klein beigegeben hat, aber hier immer mal wieder, weil es dann medial einfach eine gute Show sein muss, sich doch mal wieder aufzubäumen. Mal gucken, ob da nochmal was kommt. Aber der EUGH hat es jetzt doch erst mal im Dezember jetzt abschließend für Europa geklärt. Die juristische Hoheit gehört uns.
Sehr gut, dann werden wir jetzt noch ein bisschen darüber sprechen müssen, was wir im Salon besprechen, beziehungsweise wir haben es schon angekündigt. Wir werden uns mit Peter Thiel beschäftigen. Eine neue Biografie über ihn ist erschienen und ich glaube, wir sind da sehr gut jetzt gerade, dass wir in der Zeit, dass wir das machen. Denn Peter Thiel hat ja sich jetzt noch weiter in die Politik eingebracht. Er will da richtig investieren, will also die rechten Regierungen unterstützen. Ich bin auch sehr gespannt, wie das mit dem Ex-Kanzler von Österreich so weitergeht kurz. Also es ist ja auch dann wohl schon jetzt steht es fest, dass er zu Palantir geht oder?
Ab Februar.
Also ab Februar und da gibt es ja auch diese Thiel Connection dann offenbar nach Österreich schon länger, sonst bekommt man nicht so schnell so ein Angebot. Also eine wichtige Gestalt, die uns leider wahrscheinlich noch lange begleiten wird, wahrscheinlich auch eine wichtige Gestalt für diese Neuen Zwanziger sein wird. Deswegen lesen wir da die Biografie. Was hast du sonst auf Lager?
Ich habe einiges gelesen, habe aber noch nicht abschließend, sondern lasst euch mal überraschen. Ich lasse mich auch noch ein bisschen überraschen.
Ich hatte schon das letzte Mal angekündigt.
Aber kein großes Buch oder so.
Jetzt mache ich es wahr, Pasolinis Gedichte, die jetzt zum ersten Mal auf deutscher Schienen sind, also die, die nach seinem Tod veröffentlicht werden sollten. Um die wird es gehen. Es wird um Indien gehen. Arun Datyaraj hat ein Buch mit Essays veröffentlicht. Es wird um das Metaverse gehen, aus einer anderen Richtung. Verrate ich aber noch nicht, welchen Essay ich da vorstelle. Und die anderen zwei Texte lasse ich mal noch offen. Aber ich habe schon zwei gute Kandidaten ausgewählt.
Also Adam Tuus, ich sehe gerade meine Liste, hat wieder was geliefert über die Energiekrise 2021 mit China im Mittelpunkt. Mal schauen. Vermögenssteuerbewegungen, Rentenreformen und Babyboomer. Also mal sehen, interessantes Zeug. Aber viel Spielerei, glaube ich. Ah, einen habe ich aus der New York Times. Wie pickigen die Influencer? Ein Sack mit sehr vielen Beispielen, die wir nicht hören werden, aber ein Text, der sehr oft unterbrochen wird von Videos, wo Leute, wenn man es mal so aus dem Kontext der üblicherweise stundenlangen Streamerei und so weiter mal rausnimmt, so Heldengesänge auf China abliefern, dass es einem wirklich ein bisschen Angst und Bange wird. Also so in die Richtung. Sehr gut, Leute, dann haut rein. Wir gehen jetzt ein Schnitzel essen und wir wünschen einen guten Rutsch.
Wir sehen uns dann im neuen Jahr im Salon oder dann zur neuen Folge. Wir sagen auch danke für dieses Jahr, für die Unterstützung, für die Treue. Und wir freuen uns dann auf ein hoffentlich schnell endemisch werdendes Jahr mit vielen anderen Themen, dass man nicht mehr ganz so viel über Corona sprechen muss.
Wenn Omikron hält, was es verspricht, ist im Januar die letzte Corona-Ausgabe, wo wir das noch mal thematisieren.
Wir schauen mal.
Mal gucken, haut rein. Bis dahin, tschüss.